i didn't expect how bitter that was
going to be it's just black coffee the
beans
you know i didn't know what an americano
is until i moved to japan and you find
this watered-down coffee
yeah because i i you know i only started
caring about coffee after i moved to
japan because before i moved to japan it
was so easy to get reasonable coffee
right and i was like why is the why is
the japan coffee like so watered down
and then it's because everything here is
like americano it's just
happy new year boys and girls welcome
back to another episode hopefully it's
happening new year's happy new year for
us but maybe for you it is new year's
eve
if you're in america if you're in japan
or and around that area then happy new
year welcome to 2022. i'm joey and i'm
with gone and connor as always yeah and
it's the new year new me
you were just like serving tables i just
realized
ladies and gentlemen i always just
finished his part-time job serving some
days quickly ran down you know youtube's
been tough in 2021
did you like cut your hair because you
were just like oh it's a new year in the
podcast new year new me no that's
totally coincidental actually i was like
oh yeah this episode is going to be new
years and i'll look completely different
no i was just like i wanted to get a
haircut anyway because i was oh i am
still at the point i don't know if i
actually went back to australia but i
figured you know if i'm going to see my
parents for the first time in two years
you know maybe
get rid of the
get rid of the jesus here yeah you know
get get it get a fresh gift yeah so last
week i believe we commented on the
country thankfully opening back up and
uh that's going to be
like very dated now because as we're
filming this episode the country's
closed back down yeah so by the time
this episode comes out we don't know
where the country is going to be you
know maybe it's going to be open maybe
it's going to be close i don't know
ladies and gentlemen the omicron let's
just stop commenting on current events
yeah that's probably that's pretty good
yeah so uh yeah like literally as of
yesterday of us recording yeah japan
announced that uh they're gonna shut
down the country again yeah which is
honestly like i give them props that
they acted so goddamn quickly like this
new prime minister
he's not [ __ ] around let's pretend
let's
if this was something else right like
this was like something that japan
wasn't eager to do this would have taken
months they were like you can yeah we
have an excuse to borders oh [ __ ] yo
close them well they didn't do that with
the olympics did they oh well i mean you
know i i i think that like when i saw
online that the prime minister was like
you know i think it was like two days
prior that like the news strain had been
announced right yeah and then everyone
on twitter was like oh [ __ ] it only took
the government two days to act upon this
and i'm like oh no they didn't why is
this like a rare event isn't that
shouldn't that be normal they decided
like the moment of they just took them
two days to approve it
yeah
they they knew what they were doing yeah
but anyway current events bad
tournaments
new year it's over new year new me it's
2022 guys
did we did we okay i actually do
did we say our like new year's
resolution i think we did because chris
was on right we said what we wanted to
do remember what you said
yeah i mean i i remember what i said
well last year yeah i i don't know the
first episode of the last oh last year
it goes to show right yeah yeah [ __ ]
good with our new
sarcastically saying to chris i want to
be on the abroad in japan channel
unfortunately there you are and
unfortunately it's happened many times
yeah yeah it did oh you actually uh got
through with your new year's resolutions
what was yours the rubik's cube
was that 2019. i think that was 2019.
i've been able to do a rescue for the
past two years now at least yeah every
time like we have a rubik's cube in the
office now the old joey just goes ahead
and solves it so
he's been able to do it for a while yeah
i don't know i do not remember you
saying that as a new year's resolution i
don't think i gave a new year's
resolution because i haven't really been
a guided like
choose new year's resolutions because
for the past like three or four years i
just haven't been able to do that yeah
it must be like i feel bad for the
viewers who probably think that we have
like dementia or something that we can't
remember anything what we've said and
then we're like and we've probably had
this conversation last year we were like
oh yes so uh we just don't like them so
we just decided i know i remember i must
have said something along the lines of i
just prefer like small goals that i just
yeah bro i don't even remember what i
say like a week ago like sometimes
sometimes i have a conversation with my
mum and she was just like oh yeah when
you were talking about this i can't
believe you said that and i'm just like
mom i do not remember saying those words
at all i didn't even remember what i had
for like dinner like three days ago
right so it's like you can't expect me
to remember after like was like a
hundred plus hours of us talking on this
show but you just like remember this one
little details like nah it's not gonna
happen no because like i remember
talking about current events uh joey's
channel right now was uh he's in the
dire strike it's in the dire straits and
of course he uploads to a second channel
and i i see it's blown up right because
yeah even my mom my mum sends me a
message and she's like i just saw that
joey's channel is in trouble have you
given him a phone call to make sure he's
okay and i'm just like just breaking
down crying you know like in my bed just
sleeping into my pillow
no i mean like as of right now uh it
still hasn't been resolved but luckily i
have contacted youtube and i'm pretty
confident it's going to get resolved so
that's why i'm not like too stressed
about it but uh it was it was very
humbling when i made that video and like
so many people came to me and was like
yeah yeah i'll subscribe and all that so
thanks if you did yeah in some ways i
really like
you know if i like a situation that i
know is going to be resolved but i can
still make a video complaining you know
because it's you know it it just you get
you because you can monetize it yeah you
can market
but also it's basically like a week off
work because i don't have to upload that
one week i'm like fantastic right so i
can't upload for two weeks right because
guys i i just want to bring you this
content i really do i just oh i just
can't
well you know it's like it is
bittersweet to be fair because it's like
i i you know it's cool that there's been
like this explosion and subs on the
second channel but it's like i wish i
didn't have to resort to this you know i
wish i wish it like to my chat my main
channel literally on life support wasn't
the reason why i was getting all these
subs but you know like i mean your
second channel has basically been
becoming your anime channel for the long
time for the longest time so what if
you're just like migrating the anime man
to just now it's just joey that's just
exactly what you wanted all your career
right it could happen but at the same
time it's like you know i don't want to
lose nine years ago what if you're an
epic prank right yeah right you just
change the names and pictures of both
channels
well like so joey has a 3.1 million yeah
have you thought about it really like i
mean it could work maybe for like an
hour
yeah the good old dayton switch
it's like yeah guys up to my second
channel
jk this was the uh
and then like anime like tell everyone
like like there's a good you tell
everyone like on joey to go and comment
on the new joey channel
tell them man i really love this joey
content just spam all the comments yeah
nobody can see the old card yeah
no but um i'm hoping like next couple of
days it will get resolved
you can't upload for two weeks i can't
upload for two weeks no right but um
which sucks because it's like i have to
like because you know this especially
when you're dealing with sponsors i have
to tell them like oh sorry uh
youtube did a did a big [ __ ] and now
i can't upload it's very annoying having
to explain that to companies who clearly
don't understand like you just upload
yeah what's
your channel's still there just upload
it no no that's not how it works it's
just the life of the of a youtuber where
you just you just wake up one day maybe
and you just find out that uh maybe your
career is in danger and you're like oh
okay i guess uh all of this is like now
out of my hands it was so [ __ ] as well
because it i got the strike literally
the day the night i came back from
hokkaido right as well so it was like
after like a five-day trip with chris
and i'm like all right i gotta just
relax now just get on my computer maybe
watch some oh and my channel is about
today
amazing thanks youtube i remember i was
extremely drunk when all of my channel
got copyright claimed i remember that
okay and i was like i didn't know how to
process it because i was drunk obviously
so i was like
i was like because i just had a night
out i think that's with god we must have
a night out yeah i think i was like just
very like was was was that the night
that you accidentally deleted one of
your videos oh no there's another one
that was a different idea yeah yeah yeah
and too fair so when we would have done
that as well i would have made that
mistake
i do remember god i must sound terrible
we told that story yeah we have told
that's true okay i got really drunk and
yeah yeah yeah yeah because we had a
that was like 4 00 a.m and we were like
a friend's house but no i remember i was
i was uh i was on trip with gone and we
just had like the one night out and i
was like yeah it was a really good night
and then it was like 4am and i was about
to go to bed and then my email was like
could hear like oh fortuna just playing
in my head like youtube youtube youtube
youtube youtube copyright claim has been
fun i was like
i wouldn't even do because like you
sober up mentally yeah i'm not sober up
yeah yeah yeah but you know
you're like
oh i'm gonna sleep yeah your brain's on
100 like overdrive yeah just you can't
because the problem is you wanna sort it
out there and then right you just wanna
like get get in contact with someone
just know that you're in the process of
it being sorted out but a lot of the
times you just gotta wait and you just
gotta make noise and you just got to
like hope that someone can sort this out
for you yeah i've ever told this story
about what happened with all that
the world they're called the copyright
club i think i mean
they're not on trash
oh okay so yeah like twice now all of my
channel has been claimed
the same reason twice yeah right right
so
i was using this outro song
that i think i heard what did i get i
think i put it on skye williams's
channel which is like that's a [ __ ]
he used it as his outro yeah i thought i
liked that and also i was like i had
like 100 subs so i thought it's okay if
i just like take the same outch
of course because no one's gonna see it
and then obviously like people saw
william i loved it because he was a
banger
such a banger in fact that i had to buy
a license
and i didn't know there was an original
original song i just thought it was just
this one song right so you had the remix
version so i had the remix version right
and i didn't know that it was uh a remix
right so i went to the artist who made
it and this song had a lot of views it
was called like uh
uh do it for love or something all right
and um
i had this and i used this on every
single video oh yeah it's your outro
yeah yeah and of course
i i this this come to bite me in the ass
i i didn't just play it when the video
ended it was like it would like fade
into the video yeah yeah yeah yeah so
this will come back to bite me later
um so
i got in like 2000 maybe 17 or 16 i got
i want to say 80 of my channel copyright
claimed yeah and this is on the old
system as well where
it wouldn't tell you which i think it
didn't tell you which time it was
copyright claimed it would just say
you've been copyright claimed this is
the thing yeah
and it was by a company that was on
behalf of the artist who i purchased the
license from for 50 right i bought this
license back then i thought holy [ __ ]
this is so much money oh my god is how
much licenses cost
it's like a whole month on youtube for
me i was on my well basically at that
time it was like it was like a lot of
money you know and this is back when i
you know i was terrified of everything
and i remember i bought
licenses to fonts and [ __ ] i'm pretty
sure i'm the only person on earth who
paid for a license for a font yeah have
you paid for winrar
though
just to tell the guy i appreciate it
yeah i wouldn't
i want to meet a single person who has
paid for windows i'm going to do it on
live stream i'm going to do it live and
just see what happens i just want to see
what happens i'm just going to be the
computer just explode
we weren't designed for this stream just
ends yeah i buy wrong it's like a test
you you win life at that point you know
this is like congratulations the
simulation shuts down and you just see
like the congratulations the entire
world just like disintegrates around you
yeah you just wake up
you know you know the bible story from
like like 100 episodes again yeah it's
just that
there are people who pay for winrar and
there are people who don't
god comes
so i paid for this license and whatnot
right and uh i i angrily emailed the guy
bear in mind i was like 19 so i was like
trying to conduct myself as a
businessman but i didn't know what the
[ __ ] i was doing yeah so i angrily
emailed him from my my hotmail account
and i instructed him that i'd purchased
this license please tell this person to
stop and so this whole thing where the
guy wrote me an email being like
uh hey you have my word that you bought
the license and i had like paypal
receipts so then i had to email this
company that was claiming on behalf
which i think was distrokid
so he had put this song in a copyright
claiming thing all right so it went
around so i had a bit of difficulty it
took a while but i eventually got distro
kid to like stop claiming my stuff right
right they stopped claiming it all and
it was good i remember how i did it it
was like this long whole process was
awful
and then all good all good i kept using
the outro
after that this is where i should have
learned my lesson and changed the actual
but i thought i'd won the battle i've
done it i've done it also the song is a
banger so the song kind of slaps right
you know i i'd thought okay i'd proven
to some entity that this is legit and i
have the artist who you know says that
it's all good and i thought okay this is
this is it i'm good to use this now like
i paid for it i i got like proof and
we're all gucci yeah and so i carry on
using it
and then maybe a year later i want to
say i don't know how long exactly there
is a there was a timeline i get claimed
again this time like two-thirds of my
channel i want to say
and this is right before they added the
option to mute
right
right
so
like now if so you get copyright claimed
because sometimes there are still
[ __ ] claims they'll claim like one
second and then they'll say we hope
we're on the entire video so just just
mute it for one second yeah yeah yeah
you can mute it or delete the segment
which is one of the more positive
changes youtube has made you know
definitely and unfortunately this
situation happened i want to say like
one month before they introduced that
tool yeah so i got all of my thing
claimed and i was kind of like what the
[ __ ] do i do because two-thirds of my
revenue just like got fanossed away yeah
and this this was this happened to my
channel for about i want to say two
months straight all right so for two
months straight my earnings were like
this
yeah yeah
and i lost so much money that i never
got back so it's very very i've still to
this day quite annoyed about that um
and i i went on this whole thing of like
all right what the [ __ ] is going on so
it was like warner brothers or something
had claimed it on behalf of uh some
artists that i'd never heard of
i go and i find out that this was a
remix and i'm like oh [ __ ] i didn't know
and apparently this is like a big artist
and i'm an idiot cause i didn't know who
this person was but i never thought i
was a banger yeah right that's why i was
a banger
um
and so i was like okay
so this is weird so i i thought that he
he sold me this license and it and it
was good so i i i very confidently
counter every single claim thinking i've
got the license it's all good and they
get denied and then i appeal them as
well which is like if you lose all these
appeals your channel gets deleted yeah
so i appealed a bunch of them and for
some reason i just got denied the appeal
but nothing happened right so i just
couldn't appeal again it was weird and
so now now i was starting to be like
what the [ __ ] like what's going on like
i i counted all these claims and stuff
and nothing happened and i don't really
know what to do now so i remember i got
in touch with the guy who i bought the
license from who is the artist who made
this song i was like hey what the [ __ ]
what's going on man
you sold me a license is it good or is
it not and he's like
well
i have the license to make the remix but
i don't think and then he was like i'm
not sure what i can and can't and i'm
like oh
wow i'm like what what and then i asked
i asked a youtube man who is a lawyer
man who gave me advice that was not
legal advice every single sentence ended
with this is not legal advice yeah he
basically informed me that yeah this
license was like no good yeah it's like
nothing
whether the whether the artist knew that
or not i don't know he might genuinely
not have known mm-hmm um
so basically if he's like an indie like
artist as well
yeah yeah i assume that he didn't fully
just doing some stroke i don't think he
did i don't know i it was it was a weird
thing and i was like and so i asked the
guy i i went had like really angry dms
with him back in full flight like so
can i use this did you [ __ ] me over like
you know how much
how much this [ __ ] me like what am i
supposed to do and so in the end it
turned out yeah like i was in the wrong
because i'd been sold this bogus license
that was like not real yeah and so then
i was like well [ __ ] what do i do now
like i've just lost like
three or four i think it's three years
of like youtube work it's just gone yeah
like just can't use any of it it's so
scary right yeah and so and so i made
this video like ranting being like
[ __ ] like what do i do that's just so
[ __ ] i've been wronged et cetera et
cetera and you know and i i asked
youtube for help at the time they just
didn't help me and i was like what the
[ __ ] am i doing yeah and then
funny enough
i had a youtube partner manager before
all of this went down it was really good
surprisingly because normally they don't
talk to you right and then that person
left the company and then i got someone
new and they introduced themselves
through an email and they never heard
from them again as you know that's how
it always is
yeah and so i i went on like a mini rant
in this video being like yeah youtube's
useless they don't do anything i have
this youtube person they never talk to
me they don't help me at all after that
video goes live i got an email from a
youtube person who's like hey of course
hey i'm that person that you were like
was saying
and they were like yeah i'd actually
like to help your situation out and i
was like oh okay
great awesome
so they basically said hey so what we
can do is we can go through every single
video
and if you send me the file again
without the music in it we can replace
the video
yeah yeah
so i had to go through 200 videos and
re-render them or just cut out the music
because some of the files i didn't have
the original files anymore yeah like the
the adobe file or whatever like yeah
yeah luckily a lot of the more recent
ones the ones i liked and was more proud
of like yeah at that time the original
original file yeah so we like 200 videos
on google drive linked in like an excel
spreadsheet and then we had to one by
one like swap them but this process
wasn't even wasn't like perfect either
because videos got uploaded to the wrong
video all right
so like so you'd click on a certain
thumbnail and title and it took you to a
different video right it was like that
was the original video yeah and then
they replaced it with another video that
got put there yeah like i did like uh
there was like a i remember it was a
attack on an attack on titan impressions
and euro nice impressions yeah they both
got swapped so when people went to yuri
on ice impressions it was just me doing
attack on type of things and then when
it was when it was the other one
it was it was the other video and yeah i
sat there with youtube for like an hour
trying to explain to them what was
happening because the subtitles also got
swapped
so they were looking at the video only
in the subtitles like the raw subtitle
data yeah and they were like no no it's
the right one you're talking about yuri
on ice in the subtitles or something and
i was like no no no no the video the
video is wrong yeah and i was like
panicking and i was like i'm getting
tons of comments being like what the
[ __ ] is going on and i'm like fix this
did you not just like swap the titles
around
it was just weird because all the entire
videos see what joey's gonna do with his
channel yeah
i'm like i wonder what the side effects
are of this like so eventually we got
all sorted yeah
you just go on the channel and like why
is this attack on titan video got yuri
nice comments yeah like what's going on
there exactly so all the comments are
like that i remember yuri in an attack
on
right it's all weird and then so yeah
like again like two months later it
finally all got done yeah yeah and we
did it some of the videos like i said
they couldn't be salvaged and the reason
why it came to bite me back later was
because some outros in my videos now are
just mute yeah yeah you can't hear
anything i'll see because like i had the
exact same thing uh but after youtube
introduced the whole muting thing yeah
so i had my old old intro uh so my
current intro now is made by my friend
from uni yeah who used to be like a
music producer and it's like not even
out on like any website yeah so i know
it's like good it's like all you know
copyright free because
i had the exact same thing where like i
saw like i went on to like soundcloud
and i found like this really like bang a
song yeah um
and uh and i was like i'll call use it
as a as an outro because it's like kind
of wacky goofy like you know all the
gaming youtubers are using it at the
time and then of course uh that artist
got really popular on soundcloud
because every youtuber was using it got
a major record label because of it and
then the record label copyright claimed
all of my [ __ ] oh [ __ ] and uh and i had
and same thing i like dm the artist i
was like yeah so what's happening uh you
said i could use it she's like
yeah but i'm like a big shot now
i'm like i've got a major record label
and i'm unfortunate i can't do anything
for you but luckily this was during the
time where again youtube introduced the
muting thing so shitty of them to not if
you asked did you ask them permission
initially yeah yeah so i asked the uh so
i dm the artist initially when she was
just on soundcloud and she was like yeah
please go for it like i love that like
just just you know obviously just the
[ __ ] just like just like just link it in
the description you'll be all good i was
like oh sorry that's very nice of her
and uh and then yeah she was like oh
sorry that's uh my that's not that's not
my decision that's my labels decision so
sorry
so then i had to yeah so like if you go
back to like videos from like 2017 the
way i use that outro oh they're all mute
at the end yeah i've got a lot of videos
where i just me talking at the end i
still got comments to say being like why
does it like just go silent
yeah man
yeah i mean i've had to use that feature
for like some of my videos but like i
don't mute it i just like cut out like
the yeah now you can replace the music
yeah you can replace the music because i
believe i had to do that for trash taste
or something right because that got
copyright claimed or something
one of the specials or something oh yeah
and after dark as well for some reason
our intro for trash chase called
copyright claims and after that on
twitch on twitter
free song yeah it's a royalty-free song
but which is like no no no no
well a couple right the corporate
systems unfortunately like are really
easy to abuse like you can stick out the
old [ __ ] piece of music and start
claiming [ __ ] and it's only until
somebody like stops you yeah yeah so you
know it was really like the weirdest
copyright claimed i've gotten is like
for like anime music that i've put into
my videos like like before like anime
osc's were just like free game because
japan the anime industry didn't really
give a [ __ ] and now they're slowly
coming to realize wait a minute
youtubers use our music
how can how can this be so like now
anime osts are starting to be claimed as
well but i didn't get claimed by one of
the anime companies so i in one of my
videos i had you save run on on it um
and i got claimed and you say ryan gold
claimed but it didn't get claimed it got
claimed by a cover of you save run what
so a youtuber
a youtuber who i believe is signed with
a record label or made a video where
they made a cover of you say run and
that got like the original you say run
that i used in my video got claimed by a
cover of you save right um and yeah
that's i i'd like where do i even begin
with that you know like that's uh
i mean yeah like super early in my
youtube channel i used to do like covers
of anime songs like on guitar and piano
and stuff like that yeah reason why i
don't do that anymore is because the few
times i ever got a copyright strike yeah
not a claim a strike was from a cover i
did i did a cover of um i did a cover of
[ __ ] paranoid android by radiohead
because it was the ending to ergo proxy
right and at the time it was like i
really liked it yeah and uh yeah i got a
[ __ ] strike on it and i was like
not sure if that can also be a humble
brag because that's like saying like you
are so good
literally i thought it was the real
thought it was the original song i was
like thanks youtube but also what the
[ __ ] i've had my voice claimed a few
times actually really yeah my own videos
people trying to claim my like they're
like well i'm just talking there's
nothing is that so you know va i've seen
a tick tock of
as one dude on youtube one time he he
uploaded this original song and then got
claimed by someone yeah someone claimed
his original song right right that he
uploaded to his own channel
well because anyone anyone could put
anything called
like these companies are given like you
know free reign yeah remember remember
there was like i forgot when it was like
maybe 2018 there was like that copyright
armageddon that was happening where yeah
yeah all these like fake companies were
like going around
i mean it's still happening because like
it's not as bad as it used to be though
it's not it definitely isn't and i'm
glad like one of the positive things
youtube has done is given creators tools
like for example cut or mute the segment
that has been copyright claimed out
which we just didn't have before so if
we got a copyright claim before for like
a second of music then there was just
like nothing we could do it was just
like a dead video yeah man you know what
companies suck well there's [ __ ] like
viral hog in all those dudes the ones
that like buy viral videos oh
just go around claiming them like
armageddon they're [ __ ] awful like
nine gag and stuff like that no no no
they're like these you know you see
those watermarks on facebook you know
remember that video of that dude
punching the kangaroo yeah bible uh kind
kind of like that but a bit different
because live bible they don't really
they don't normally go around copyright
claims yeah like that that video right
the the person who had that video sold
it to this company right and then what
they do is everyone who's then
uh talking about it or showing it
they'll just go around copyright
claiming everything and any of these
news networks
well that's what it's the business model
like they they buy these videos for like
very cheap
even like have you have you never had
offers from people who want to buy your
videos
they'll go around buying them and then
just claim everything and it's just yeah
it's really [ __ ] because people react to
stuff on stream as well
yeah that's true and also the worst
thing is about that luckily 99 cents you
will never have to experience is that
these copyright claims right sometimes
they're like really [ __ ] generous
with the timing on the video like so
they have to say what time in the video
they copyright collection yeah and
sometimes they'll add on like five or
ten seconds oh
yeah like a piece of [ __ ] now i've got
to like this there's like a clear edit
and everything i've gotta edit out or
mute [ __ ] because yeah because you don't
get to contest no time so whatever the
time is that's like if you want to mute
the the copyrighted content you don't
get to say where it is yeah whatever
they submitted is it so one time on one
video i remember i reacted to like a
clip or something on like on a live
stream or something on connor talk and
uh they claimed it and i was like yeah
it's fair enough but then they claimed
like 40 seconds extra i have nothing to
do with said clip wow and i was like wow
dude like really like like a force they
own your reaction as well apparently no
no
[ __ ] my
videos like that where i react shadow
and i don't give a [ __ ] but yeah it's
like bro what are you doing don't claim
[ __ ] that isn't the video like come on
you're just lazy
that's the problem right it's like i
feel like youtube has done a really good
job of like trying to make the playing
field as fair as possible right like
yeah only recently they added that whole
thing of like
how uh during an appealing process the
money that the video accumulates goes
into what's called escrow which is like
kind of what you should have done yeah
yeah which is kind of like it doesn't go
to the
person who is the supposed copyright
holder or the video owner it kind of
like is floating in the cloud until it's
resolved yeah it's it's just great it's
like being put in the pool yeah no one
can get that until the uh copyright
situation is resolved which is fantastic
but like at the same time even today i
feel the
you know the advantage is still in the
claimant yeah like clearly youtube is
like yeah you know obviously if you're
gonna go out of your way to claim
something copyright wise then you must
have a good reason for it but yeah a lot
of companies don't thank you to alien
clothing for sponsoring this video today
alien is an indie streetwear clothing
company started in early 2017 by youtube
creator elvis the alien who also happens
to be a personal friend with the support
and love from the youtube community has
grown beyond his wildest dreams obvious
created alien for people like him who
love games anime movies and anything
science fiction
just like you joey i love all of those
things impress your grandma by wearing a
monster android or aliens stay spaced
out and never compromise your sense of
self alien helps people who wish to
embrace the bold and strange through
clothing expression aliens designs are
very carefully created by some of the
best artists from around the world the
items are printed shipped and handled
with care from their team in canada get
what you can before they're sold out
most items are never restocked but fear
not alien is constantly coming out with
new creative designs and alien uses only
the best quality fabrics available on
the market while still trying their best
to keep every item affordable alien
items are sold by popular skate shop
zoomies in canada and hope to expand
more in future so if you want to save 20
off using the code trash taste any
orders over 100 get free shipping damn
in case you missed that it's
a-y-y-l-i-e-nclothing.com
so smash that link in the description to
get your own alien products today thank
you alien clothing for sponsoring this
episode back to the video um but
speaking of like other changes that
youtube has made oh yeah now the dust is
settled on the dislike thing yeah so
like uh has dislikes been removed i'm
very confused because i can still see
them on my channel it's it's a slow on
your channel yeah yeah yeah
yeah on anyone else's channel though it
should be completely gone no i can still
see it on videos i think i mean let me
check let me check right now i know i
know that
oh no it's gone no
no literally i was literally it's
feeling that for days no no i literally
i literally looked at [ __ ] videos
yesterday and i was just like where does
the dislike channel go when is the
dislikes going
it was yeah it was like it's getting
like slowly implemented i think so not
all channel owners can see it but like
at least with your own content you can
still see your dislikes which goes
completely against the argument that
youtube made as to why they wanted to
get rid of the dislikes because i
remember i made a video on a second
channel and one of the youtube's
reasonings for getting rid of the
dislike button was that like oh it you
know if you see dislikes on your videos
it discourages smaller creators you know
like perhaps you know they're getting
dislike bomb perhaps they're getting
bullied and no one likes to see a bunch
of dislikes
yeah you can still see dislikes on your
own videos so what the [ __ ]
you know i'm just glad they're standing
up for the small creators all two of
them or something that exists on the
entire platform of youtube um that have
ever complained about this because like
i was talking to this about with a bunch
of other youtubers and i was i asked
them do you know a single creator in
your field that has ever complained
about disliked bombs like whatever size
yeah and not a single person i know has
ever been like
ever been like a target of dislike bombs
to the point where it actually actively
ruins their channel yeah you know have
you ever received a lot of dislikes yeah
i mean yeah for i mean because i feel me
and god make more opinionated videos
yeah right so you know obviously there
are some opinions i've said in the past
that people yeah i'm very happy with you
had a lot of dislikes on one video i've
had some videos that didn't do as well
what what do you classify as a lot of
dislikes
more than like 10 percent yeah 10 is
quite a lot yeah okay yeah i've had a
few videos but not that much i don't
have that much most of it is like the
more the more controversial opinion
videos yeah um but in people who didn't
like watch the videos
i think the only one was the
christian one yeah yeah understandable
but uh yeah
yeah but yeah yeah no i've had a few
where it's like it's but it you know
when i look back on those videos or like
how i presented them i can see why they
got dislike bomb and i don't really
blame them for it i guess like i
remember like i think one that really
blew up recently that got quite a few
dislikes i think it is like yeah nine to
one is uh it's an old let's fight
episode where the title of it is uh
berserk is not a masterpiece
i think he's just like and it's like
right now i think it's like 10 yeah 15
dislike and it only blew up after miura
sensei's passing right because obviously
people were searching
and obviously if you watch the video i
argue against you you'd know that joey
is like the biggest berserk simp yeah
like ever
that was the title i used that because
that was one of the opinions i got and i
fought against it but clearly people you
know don't watch it all the way through
or up to that point so they just see the
title and they think oh this guy hates
berserk dislike in some ways i you know
i personally like the dislike button but
in other ways i think it doesn't really
do anything and it doesn't serve
the only place you actively dislike the
video yeah yeah yeah okay
but here's the problem right for what
reason yeah this is this is the problem
right there's no agreed-upon consensus
on when you dislike right it's you could
dislike because you disagree with the
opinion you could dislike because you
didn't enjoy the video as much as
another one you could dislike because
you just don't like the person yeah i
feel like it's the dislike although is
sometimes helpful on a tutorial yes it's
very black and white is the tutorial not
good dislike yeah right when it comes to
like your videos i feel like the dislike
bar
doesn't serve the same purpose as it
does on a tutorial where information is
actually important i i think it serves a
purpose when you know like you really
[ __ ] up you know again yeah again yeah
yeah you've like purposely made like a
very controversial yeah yeah yeah the
more i think about it the more i think
yeah okay in some ways the dislike
dislike unlike bar is [ __ ] useless
like it doesn't mean anything it doesn't
with 99 of videos i think is completely
useless and only with tutorials and
knowing when you [ __ ] up that's
literally the only reason well i mean i
mean there is also some catharsis to
being able to dislike a video and just
like you see sometimes you see a video
and it's so outrageous and you want to
know that you're not the only [ __ ]
person who thinks that this video is a
like this is a shitty video or something
right and you go to the dislike bar and
you're like thank god i'm not the only
one you know there is some catharsis
it's like going on to a video and seeing
comments are disabled and i'm just like
[ __ ] you
[ __ ] you but that's that that's way no
balls
the likes of this like bar is like
nothing it's the comments that matter i
think that and and when they come to
disabled they get way more likely right
like to me it's like i i don't mind if
you disagree with an opinion i make on a
video but i would much rather you leave
a comment
explaining why you dislike it or why you
are against whatever i said in that
video rather than just like leaving a
dislike because as you said a dislike
can mean a million different things
because you know sometimes people will
be like this video wasn't as good as
another one does that mean that that
person disliked it and is that is that
like fair because if i didn't like a
video that someone made or i liked
another one more i wouldn't personally
dislike no i mean but that's how i do it
right so
to me trying to like extrapolate any
information from this random just metric
that doesn't mean [ __ ] like it just it
doesn't help me like when i see a video
that has 99.9 percent likes i'm like
okay now i see a video with 99.8 likes
i'm like
what's the difference here
like did they get just more likes than
previously or like less dislikes i don't
really understand yeah but i mean like i
think it is useful not in like the small
percentages but in like the large
percentages right because most videos on
youtube should have like an above ninety
percent like ratio like like to this i
think it's actually 99 it's like the is
like normally good 95 is where you're
getting to like all right maybe you've
said something like a little bad if it's
10 if you have nine to one ratio you're
probably [ __ ] up oh no you haven't
[ __ ] up you've just pissed off
my experiences you've probably pissed
off
a group a certain community or a certain
group you know and then you get to like
the 50 percent and that's when you know
that something big has like yeah because
your core audience will always like
that's yeah i mean that's really but
that doesn't necessarily like for
example like you know a channel i like
to watch a lot of needle draw who does
like a lot of music reviews right yeah
he's had a couple of recent uh before
the dislikes disappeared he's had a
couple of videos
that were like you know 40 likes yeah
but it was still uh like a good video it
was just the thing his opinion about it
obviously didn't you know coincide with
the general public about it right so but
like what does that as a viewer what do
i then gather from that video like right
i'm like is this a bad video yeah is it
does it does he say something that's
flat out wrong did you say something
that a lot of people just don't agree
with like it doesn't really tell you
anything it's a mixture of all those
right yeah and that's why you have to go
down into the comments after that to be
like okay what is the reasoning behind
this massive dislike yeah but like i
feel like youtube removing this way for
viewers to express themselves or like
the distaste of a video they're going to
find other ways to express their
distaste towards a video well yeah like
i'm sure like rationing is just right
yeah it's it's going to now be a [ __ ]
thing in the youtube sphere it's like it
wasn't already [ __ ] annoying yeah i i
can't wait to like comments to like
ratio youtube videos now because that's
just that's what's going to happen you
know it's it's
viewers always find out like audiences
always find a way to show their dislike
yeah it's either the youtube comments
are going to get more toxic or other
social media platforms that that
particular youtuber is known to be on is
going to get more toxic because like the
biggest thing that annoys me is you know
the tutorials and stuff because that you
know you are very much removing an easy
way to discern whether a tutorial is
right or whether a certain video is
right because let's say let's say you
upload a shitty tutorial or you upload a
scam right you disable comments but
likes and dislikes are still available
are still up in the open so you you're
kind of just like you you're just kind
of like taking a risk on whether you
should listen to them right because you
don't know how many people are disabled
but also likes are very easy to
manipulate as well like that's another
thing well but like the i would argue a
smaller level yeah
but i would argue that now that you
can't even see the dislikes anymore
there's not even a point of like
disabling likes and dislikes anymore
right because it's just in a constant
disabled state right because it's like
you can only say like say for example
there was a scam video yeah if they
disable the comments now what's the only
thing you can see is the likes it's like
yeah i mean you can't do anything about
it because like i i think youtube were
trying to go with something
similar to what instagram did with their
likes about making like likes not public
except for the poster and like for
instagram i get it for that you know for
that platform i think it made sense
because they reverted it hmm they
reverted it did they yeah when i can see
all the likes yeah they reverted yeah
they reverted it
since how long like a long time now holy
[ __ ] okay
under the impression that that was yeah
yeah yeah yeah well we can see how often
god goes on instagram it's no big secret
that i don't go on instagram so uh i
guess my point is now mute
well [ __ ]
i'm glad you guys stopped me before i
was starting before i was going to start
spewing a lot of balls
no they shot for me they shot for me
yeah they shot for me
i think they might be slowly rolling it
back out or you have to like
maybe opt into it or something i don't
know but let's see okay that must be
data that's [ __ ] that on their end right
that like says hey you know when people
see likes it's good for us yeah yeah and
i i don't know what that is i can only
probably it's probably if people can see
like it just keeps them on the platform
because viewers want to feel like
they're having some like like they can
contribute in some way shape or form
well they want to see a metric and they
want to see that metric go up with the
with the youtube one the main
speculation was that brands weren't
happy with the dislike bar yeah now i'm
i in some ways i feel like that's too
easy of an explanation yeah i feel like
youtube in the past hasn't i i don't
think they've been that catering of
brands
i don't know i could be wrong here i
feel like they must have some data that
backs up that removing dislikes will
lead to better views or something yeah i
mean because there's no way that
you should each team seems too selfish
to yeah to do something for brands it
seems like i feel like it just happens
to be no so uh so the youtube creators
uh channel on youtube made a video it's
like a three minute video that was like
very concise saying why they were moving
it yeah was it the dude who's like uh is
that the one that the guy was like
sitting there yeah yeah the guy's just
like sitting there being like this is
the reason why we're gonna do it nice
and quick you know i give him props for
that at least it wasn't like a [ __ ]
30 minute explanation video yeah but
like they gave him another [ __ ] like
nick over yeah exactly exactly it was
nice and concise which is nice but um
yeah one of the reasons they gave was
like oh yeah we saw a metric uh that uh
we tested upon millions of users don't
know how true that is that uh apparently
the amount of dislikes does not change
uh the watch time of that video i
believe that no i believe that yeah and
i'm like yeah i mean of course i don't
you that's not a reason though to get
rid of it with dislikes yeah exactly
because i argued being like well yeah
what if you're watching like an apology
video that's like 40 minutes long right
this i'm sure there's a lot of dislikes
on it but people want to see it until
yeah yeah i mean youtuber has one
priority it's making people watch longer
yeah there must be some some evidence to
to prove that i do getting rid of it
makes people watch that i did find it
funny though that the last point they
gave that was like and the last question
is did we get rid of the dislike button
because of youtube rewind they brought
that point yeah
and dude i've never seen a guy say no
with such copium in my life
he was like no no
you can see the copy i mean
you could see how many times he had to
film that to not to like sound genuine
to like get the most genuine take that
he could
because he knew like people were going
to be watching this under a microscope
yeah at like 0.25 speed or something to
be like well the inflection in his voice
kind of leads me to believe that youtube
made himself i heard a slight vibrato in
his voice meaning he is about to start
crying at any minute
i just wish they would uh tell us the
truth and give us some data but they're
not going to do that why would we no no
no i mean i mean what like
what no not not annoyed me but the way
what uh
really made me suspicious was the way
they framed it to like oh we're doing
you guys yeah you asked for this
don't don't thank us later please please
hold the applause but we are helping you
for your mental health and it's just
like literally no creator i have talked
to or ever heard of like ask youtube to
do this and they framed it in a way that
they're doing it for their creativity
ever seen a youtube creator make a video
in front of the camera going guys my
mental health is deteriorating from all
these dislikes i'm getting man [ __ ] no
of course not it's the [ __ ] algorithm
that's like demanding youtube's to not
take a break it's the one time a
corporation has said don't worry guys
we've heard you and the cr the the the
audience didn't actually say anything
yeah we have been silent
you've had
[Music]
it's literally the i've saved the day
but you haven't done anything they just
leave
you're welcome i'll see ya
oh my god so i've uh finally started to
settle in my new place now oh yeah um
yeah we are 20 years later 20 years
later you know
um you know hosted uh the house warming
unfortunately joey couldn't make it
because you were busy with the uh
yeah i will say yeah lovely lasagna yeah
i will say ever since that day so okay
so i don't know if i've told the story
of the world famous lasagna yeah which
it's it's not world famous but it's
about to be okay it's now it's about to
be so
um so in japan i don't know why but you
can get a lot of good italian food in
japan but for some reason you just can't
get lasagna like no italian restaurant
in japan for some reason serves lasagna
and the few that they do they definitely
don't serve good lasagna yeah so because
of this i would just like look i've been
living in japan for a year i'm craving
lasagna so what better way to do it then
just learn how to do it yourself absorb
myself [ __ ] uh literally [ __ ]
thanos i'll [ __ ] do it myself right
so about a year ago i didn't even
realize i was a fan of reference i just
said it is it a thanos reference yeah i
don't know
it's the one where he takes a [ __ ]
and says fine i'll do it myself yeah
yeah i haven't seen the movie i just see
that it's a pretty famous music this is
the most generic line that could be
attached to any character i could say
anything i could be like oh my penis is
a little lychee's like i remember that i
said
i'll do it myself after myself
so about a year ago i learned how to
cook lasagna and i cook it once right i
i cook it once and it was like it was
like mediocre lasagna all right and uh
it's a difficult dish right yeah i mean
kind of
lego but with pasta yeah it's it's like
it's cool it's it's a it's a pasta cake
right it's just it's just concentrated
pasta with meat sauce
that's kind of that's kind of what it is
it's like all the flavor of pesto bowl
layers very precisely right yeah right
so
deep doing quarantine uh sometimes we
would you know have have dinner parties
where we we would invite people over or
just people would come over yeah and one
day sydney cindy invites connor roven
and she says oh you could have some of
gant's world famous lasagna and i'm just
like and scott is like what i'm just
like what what do you mean world famous
cindy i've cooked it once
and ever since she said that because she
didn't say it to connor she said it to
me lynn as well and so for like a good
five months people have like people have
built up this idea that i make world
famous lasagna it's a joke it's it's
it's just that just out here like doing
just misinformation yeah i just dropped
people out if you had a go on sport
famous lasagna yeah
and so
and so the first time i actually cook it
for like for like may lin yeah
maitland's the one i want to please the
most of course yeah you got to get that
good goo yeah yeah of course of course
because if if you can please mail in
with a meal you can you know it's good
it's basically it's basically michelin
star at that point it is world famous so
the first time i cook it was at maelyn's
house and when you're cooking in a in a
kitchen that you're unfamiliar with with
equipment that you don't know you know
sometimes
sometimes you have an oven and you don't
know you like with japanese ovens
especially the ones that aren't
pre-built but the ones that you buy
they say a temperature but they don't
actually the actual temperature varies
depending on what oven and what brand
you buy right that's true yeah so i
remember first time i cooked this
lasagna was uh for the public was that
mayolin's house
for the public for the world it's so
world famous it's so world famous to
cook it and i i was like i was like
[ __ ] sweating because like weeks
before
i come to i come to mainland's house to
cook it mailing was like can't wait for
the world famous lasagna you know what
you know what i'm i'ma give you a
[ __ ] google review just you know
just to see if it is actually world
famous i'm like for [ __ ] sake man this
this joke has gone the pressure
i have this is like this is like cooking
for gordon ramsay or something right i
feel like i'm part of like kitchen
nightmares or something right now so i'm
i'm cooking i'm cooking at mailing's
house and uh it takes a while to get
lasagna right because it's not it's not
like an easy dish you gotta cook the
meat sauce you gotta like difficult you
gotta layer it up and i wasn't familiar
with maelyn's oven i'd cooked it a bunch
of times my own oven and the first time
i cook it in mainland's oven something
that an experienced chef would say yeah
i cook it in mainland's oven and
unfortunately it was
it wasn't hot enough her oven didn't go
hot enough so i liked it so you had a
you had a crispy lasagna yeah so i
cooked it and a little al dente lasagna
yeah so that is
crispy what's that what's the crispy one
not elder what what is al dente i don't
know she's not just satisfied
means uh to the bite right so it's like
just right softness yeah i think yeah
italians please confirm you say italian
words like just say that it was
definitely i cook my lasagna mamma mia
yeah i mean it wasn't it wasn't fully
cooked but the inside was definitely as
gordon ramsay would say [ __ ] raw
i mean even if lasagna is like raw i'm
like this is still pretty [ __ ] cool i
don't mind my lasagna a little crunchy i
mean okay connor connor enjoyed it when
when i could not a picky man with
lasagna yeah i mean as long as you have
all the ingredients in here yeah i mean
the meat sauce is pretty good but melon
nothing goes past melissa she takes one
bite and she's like this is raw
this is this is raw and i'm just like
the energy of gordon ramsay yeah i'm
just like uh
you know my my cooking career is over
after one dish you know this is this is
it i'm gonna i'm gonna
now i'm never going to cook again i'm
just like i got to experience this toy
movie yeah in like real time
and so uh and so that was the last time
i cooked uh lasagna for other people to
taste
yeah until until
until this housewarming party where
sydney obviously invites you know uh
sydney advice everyone and she sends
people
she sends people this menu as well
things that we were going to cook right
right and i'm just like sydney why would
you do that and without my knowledge she
said she said i would be cooking the
world famous lasagna
literally on the menu trying to bring
the old man out of retirement try and
get him back in the game
and yeah i feel like a retired hero or
something you know i'm just like sydney
i've never done that in years i'm past
my prime now i can't do it i can't do it
cindy don't make me do it i'm sure she's
like gone it's out maelyn's coming you
need to do it right and so i'm so like
i'm i'm like sweating now so
so a few days before the lasagna if a
few days before the housewarming yeah i
have a practice run oh my god
i actually i actually got so nervous
that i'm just like i need to uh i need
to i need to practice i need to like i
need to get uh my my lasagna making
skills are a little rusty i need i need
to get back on the get back on the
pedestal see how it's done again um and
so
yeah so i've got some oil in these bones
yeah so i did my lasagna and cindy loves
it but i'm just like i can do better i
need to do better
i make something let's go further beyond
i make some mental notes before the
before the day about what i'm about like
the small changes i'm going to make to
the recipe like the small changes are
going to make to the preparation and
everything and so the day comes it's
like you're going to like a bake-off it
is
this is
a joke like imagine cooking for maelyn
you know but it's like your own i would
never dare to but it's your own personal
recipe like i i think i would actually
rather cook for gordon ramsay at this
point um and so
everyone comes everyone comes and you
know everyone has all the different you
know side dishes we have some meatballs
we have some other things
but the lasagna is the main dish and
like everyone's everyone's having a
merry time i'm [ __ ] sweating not just
because of the heat from the oven but
i'm sweating out of nerves man i look
very nervous i do remember you looking
really nice yeah i remember like i
remember everyone coming in everyone
coming in like sydney just like greeting
everyone everyone's being social and i
was like don't talk to me don't talk to
me i'm making like i'm standing right
now i'm making lasagna connor's like yo
go on can i see your office and i'm just
like no connor i'll show you after i
finish this [ __ ] lasagna
and then and then i'll be social and
i'll be a good host yeah but until the
design is done nothing is happening and
so
um and so i cooked this on lasagna it's
an hour after sydney had said that the
designer would be finished i don't care
you can't rush perfection
and then i and then i and then i finish
it and then i take it out
and then this is a really weird
experience people start crowding around
this lasagna right it's like oh yeah
people started crowding that around this
design and you know i'm gonna say it
looks [ __ ] good right no it's like i
mean i saw the photos it looks good
there's the thing about lasagna right
that you know anyone who loves lasagna
will understand is it the first
spatula the first serving is always the
best one yeah because the more the more
people start chunking out that lasagna
the more sloppy it becomes yeah don't
get me wrong it's not like lasagna is
the cleanest thing on earth yeah but the
first the first spatula scoop is the
best one yeah so you get the perfect
ratio yeah yeah yeah because like you
know i needed to make sure like the
cheese was like perfectly toasted
because it can't be like raw cheese and
like the edges need to be like a little
bit crispy a little bit burnt right
that's that's to me that's a good
lasagna you can't have like a completely
raw but not too overburnt lasagna and so
i remember i remember finishing it
everyone's taking a picture i'm like
melin
have the first taste
the spotlight comes on silent the room
is silent right i give her the dish
she like she like takes one bite right
and it's just like the longest [ __ ]
few seconds of my life right i see you
chewing this lasagna and i'm just like
my life is like flashing before my eyes
right now and she's just like
oh [ __ ]
you've leveled up
i can't explain the [ __ ] euphoria
that just went over my body man
it was very good it was like it was
literally that japanese going
it was good
very good i have to say i can confirm
it's great
it's like a lost food wars episode it
was to be honest i don't remember any of
the other food that was there yeah i
remember the ladies yeah it must be good
there were sandwiches there was there's
alright
i don't know i don't even i i know there
was a menu but i can't remember anything
else on the menu i mean
what what what does it matter when you
had the world famous lasagna i just i
just wanted to be like really
pretentious about it just be like
like a childhood flashback
maybe i hope so but like ever since that
point i'm just like
damn cooking's fun cooking for other
people can be fun so
who would have thought yeah so uh ever
since ever since then ever since then me
and sunny have been cooking almost like
every day so we used to like uber eats
almost every day and a big a big thing a
big deal is because we do have a
dishwasher now so uh we don't have to
wash dishes ourselves anymore and that
takes so much of the effort out in the
cooking process because right you know i
like i find i find like i find cooking
relaxing you know i actually find it
relaxing to chop up the onions or chop
up the vegetables or whatever prepare
the dish cook the dish it's the it's the
clearing up that is always put me off
cooking all right ever since i've gotten
the dishwasher cooking has actually been
an enjoyable experience for me yeah i
feel the more i'm doing it now like i
used to [ __ ] dread it like i it was
just like stressful even like following
the menu or the recipe
somehow i [ __ ] it up in some regard i
don't know i was like i'm following the
recipe how does this taste like [ __ ]
yeah yeah and but like now the more i'm
like slowly sounds like hell bucky cook
and like you know trying out like really
easy like pastas and like you know
something that is very difficult to [ __ ]
up kind of thing i'm like oh
wow
it's kind of fun what the [ __ ]
is this what is this what it feels like
to be like good at something yeah and
it's just like when you when you see
people eating your meal and they're just
enjoying it and feeling happy i'm like
oh this is how chefs feel oh my god oh
my god i think i think i found like a
new hobby or something because it's uh
genuinely like a good feeling to cook
something that you're proud of and
people also enjoy your cooking i get it
now mom i get it okay i guess i am i get
why you was always like eagle-eyed on me
whenever i'd like eat any of your meals
okay i get it now i like cooking it's
just a lot of work but also
um i i'm also really bad with portion
control
right when i make food i make food like
a lot like a feast yeah
i used to make a lot of lasagna from
walls is that i would then eat lasagna
you make a little lasagna you know yeah
yeah yeah but is it world famous
nobody's had it that's it
well no no i'm curious now i'm curious
we're about to have a lasagna
one time i made a lasagna right i was
like oh i totally forgot to make the
white sauce layer wherever right right
and i was like why does this taste like
bricks
because there was like no like white
layer to balance out the tomatoes yeah
but yeah so i i would have make lasagna
i always liked leftover lasagna more
than lasagna
really something about lasagna sometimes
that like the next day when you when you
heat it up it's like perfect yeah it's
cause it's so thick right yeah it's so
thick it kind of gets i don't know try
it guys it's like i i have tried it it's
like it's like how leftover deep dish
pizza tastes better than the fresh deep
sometimes yeah sometimes i don't know
why but at least at least the lasagna
that i made i don't know maybe it was
like are you talking about microwaved
lasagna or do you just eat it straight
out of the [ __ ] fridge
uh i don't know like properly made
lasagna and then i would like put it
back in the next day yeah i'll put it
back in the oven yeah yeah oh okay
it's good yeah i think maybe it's
because like the the the juices like
coagulate yeah like solid it like seeps
in right like you could like cut through
it like a cake yeah
whereas lasagna that goes [ __ ]
everywhere yeah i think we're wrong i
might i generally prefer normal lasagna
but about when i used to make it that
for some reason i liked it the day after
more no i get that i don't know why it's
like a hurry
no i've heard that that's like the
biggest fallacy i've ever heard because
i've had i've had day old curry it
definitely doesn't taste as good as like
what kind of curry though indian curry
right because i understand why okay
indian curry may not be the same because
in with japanese curry it's definitely
better the day after yeah because it's
it's taken the time for like everything
to like
sarah are you uh sorry okay hong kong
but like i was telling japanese curry
tastes to say no matter what i feel
so yeah i i feel like i've never had bad
curry but i've never had curry that's
like made me like [ __ ] amazed about
how good it is it is the most like six
out of ten cups there's some like
gourmet ones where they use like really
rich stock and they have like really
like uh good quality beef bites yeah at
the end of the day it's still generally
it's still a japanese car yeah exactly
um with pizza
i do do you like i was wondering about
this because you know there's people who
like purists they're like stone-baked uh
uh what's uh where was it from uh napoli
napoli like that's the only style that's
the correct style which type of pizza is
your favorite style i was just curious
yeah i do like stone base stone bait is
the only pizza where i can eat the crust
okay because okay because like some like
sourdough stone bay pizza oh my god okay
yeah i'm a crust i'm a cross hater but
i'm like i'm gonna eat that [ __ ]
crust i'm gonna enjoy it okay american
pizza is the best pizza i think like
what like what kind of american pizza
like a new york pizza that's like the
best to be fair new york pizza is pretty
[ __ ] bomb they i think american style
of making pizza is the best way
i uh i love stone bake i love stone bake
right i love it don't get me wrong but
like there i don't know what it is about
americans italians italians i i hear you
italians like i thought
a whole generation just like died
here's my argument right the thing with
the thing with stone baked pizza that
sometimes kind of pisses me off why are
they so goddamn light with the toppings
like they put like one pepperoni on it
and call it a day you know which i get
it you don't you don't like submerge it
but also everything falls off like
immediately as well i think it's awesome
nothing stays in place
isn't that based off
isn't that based off like the it's
either napoli or the other type of uh
italian pizza but like it's not supposed
to be a heavy meal yeah it's supposed to
be very very lovely i don't know which
one it is yeah i love the heaviness of
american pizza right right like it's
like a it's all like a nice why american
pizza what do you mean because there's
so many different types well the
american style of making pizza is like
the
from what i understand like new york
where it's like dominant yeah it's like
perfectly constructed right where it's
like this it's this slice that like is
very solid on its own like when it's cut
up nothing like falls off nothing like
[ __ ] slips off or anything it's a
nice solid bit of pizza i love it also
one thing i tried which i thought was
going to be disgusting right this is
this is vile i know it sounds gross hear
me out right
i had this do you like the grease do you
like the grease yes so
hold on hold on
okay i'm listening i tried the hot dog
in the crushed pizza and i [ __ ] loved
it hot oh like a like a hot dog in the
crust all right i [ __ ] i really
enjoyed it do you like cheesy crust
yes but i like the hot dog one more
really
what about an extra meal but what if you
put the cheese inside of the hot dog and
then you put that in the crust oh that's
that's that's just not even a crust
anymore like whenever whenever whenever
people whenever people say oh but do you
eat stuffed crust stuffed brush is good
stuffed crust is what you eat when
you're like when you don't want to
actually eat crust okay it's a
mozzarella stick okay and this is this
is just a [ __ ] hot dog okay
you're eating you're eating a pizza with
a hot dog at the end i like it
i like the hot dog you get it in japan
oh really yeah pizza hut do it oh
you're not going to pretend that this is
better than stone baked pizza or like a
fresh honestly fresh [ __ ] pizza okay
but okay but in japan no way
no [ __ ] way am i listening to this
right now in japan
there's in japan okay there's two types
of pizza in japan right yeah there's
pizza and then there's pizza yeah all
right two different things no i'm not
you guys are but it is
like an hour left on this recording can
we order a pizza hot pizza with sausage
in the crunch i actually want to try it
i'm just saying we should do it we
should all have a live reaction yeah why
why not because i want to see your
reaction i want to see your hot dog
crust pizza it's a hot dog crust pizza
camera have your head on i've never
tried it yeah i want to see how have you
never tried it because i barely eat
cheesy crust i just want like a regular
crust i'm pretty sure they have it man
i'm telling you why do you like cheesy
crust it's too heavy
and you want a hot dog crust no honestly
it's like it's so good it's like a very
tight hot dog it's like so it's like
wrapped around it's like a bite-sized
hot dog it's like a hot dog burrito bro
it's so good
i need to check if they still have yeah
so so in japan right there's there's two
types of pizza there's pizza which is
like stuff like pizza hut domino's
american pizza basically right and then
there's pizza which is the italian pizza
yeah right so like when if you ever go
to like a an italian like restaurant or
whatever or establishment
you'll be able to know the difference
between like the italian like
stone-baked stuff that god likes and
then the american stuff that conor likes
so at least gusting at least japan has
like made a distinction being like you
know at least they're not one of those
countries that are like all pizza is the
same like i remember when i first went
to new york right and i had my first
like new york pizza and the selling
point of this pizza uh was that you
could literally just kill your face you
could literally tilt the pizza and you
could see the oil dripping off it and
i'm just like how is this a selling
point you're meant to make this
appetizing
this is just pure fat that's like
rolling off now i i but i went to a
place in new york that was like i guess
like kind of famous in new york i forgot
what it was but like
it's they're famous for like dabbing the
oil off pizza off the pizza so it's a
really really it's it's a massive pizza
but it's really thin and really light
yeah so like i don't know about like the
full or like oil dripping off thing like
if that was a good point
but like the point is you're still
dabbing off the oil because there is so
much oil on the pizza right right and to
me that's that's not that's not
appetizing i don't know like when i see
that much oil on anything that just i
don't want to eat it you know i i can i
can feel i can feel my arteries just
clogging up as much as like you know
there's a place called pizza slice in
shibuya that's really good that does uh
new york style pizza [ __ ] bomb i can
only go there maybe like once a month
though because my god after two slices i
am like about to explore look look i i
get it where you know i i get that it's
a nice fast meal it feels good it feels
unhealthy but to say that it is better
than stone baked pizza that's where i
draw the line man no [ __ ] way if i
had to choose oh god so hard i just i
just like pizza in general yeah
it's all delicious
i'm not saying that stone bait is not
delicious yeah it is yeah i'm not i'm
not saying that new york pizza is not
delicious as well in its own way because
like both types of pizza have their
benefits because because like the only
thing can be an everyday meal the the
only pizza that i'd say the americans do
the best is chicago pizza she can't push
stuff
but like that's like that's not even
that's not even nowhere else even does
it not a pizza it's a pie no no yeah
exactly it's it's not a pizza it's a
pizza lasagna but it's a pizza lasagna
that's what that's what chicago deep
dish pizza is and that's why it's
[ __ ] amazing
this episode is sponsored by honey we
all shop online we've established that
by now yes and we've all seen that promo
code field taunters at the checkout
every time every time connor but thanks
to honey oh manually searching for
coupon codes is a thing of the past
because honey is the free browser
extension that scours the internet for
promo codes and applies the best what it
finds to your cart hunting supports over
30 000 online stores they range from
sites that have tech gaming products to
popular fashion brands and even food
delivery all right let me tell you how
this works imagine you're shopping one
of your favorite sites
rather check out once again and then the
honey button drops down and all we have
to do is click apply coupons wait a few
seconds as honey searches for coupons it
can find for that site and if honey
finds a working coupon your watch as the
prices drop
joe what'd you say for honey so i bought
a brand new tripod for my brand new
camera
i saved the whopping 35
i didn't even know you could save honey
on tripods joey oh god it's because
honey can save you money on pretty much
anything am i getting it you'll be doing
yourself for solid and also supporting
this podcast so what are you waiting for
get honey for free at joinhoney.com
trash taste that's join honey.com
trash taste joey with the outro back to
the show you know for me there's
something about the filling-ness of an
american pizza style american pizza
style that i i love so much yeah i get
that like i love i really really miss
domino's pizza in the uk it was so good
i love that pizza what's different about
it in the uk
i don't know i don't know why it's so
good i i don't know i think it's just
biased i think it just tastes the same
that's that's me i i did you like i've
had dominoes around like lots of
different places and they all kind of
taste so i i had little caesars pizza in
america right and i thought it was
delicious
the mini pizzas the bigger ones are the
bigger ones like five dollar for like a
large right and everyone was saying like
bro it's like the worst pizza on earth
yeah i actually like like it i like oven
pizza it's not really great i had it i
liked it i liked it i'd much rather
dominos than literally i like little
caesars it was and also i'm just
convinced you don't have taste buds no
i'm like the the more the more you talk
the more i'm just like no no no
also
my enjoyment of it also increases
knowing that for all of that for five
dollars that's insane
what
the taste is good and it's only like
it's only heightened by the fact that
it's simply five dollars
for this massive like this could feed
the entire [ __ ] last supper this
little caesar pizza yeah because it's
not that good that doesn't affect the
taste i don't know it does it most come
on dude you go to a place right the
price affects the way you see the food
it does yes like when you get that's
exactly why little caesars taste like a
five dollar pizza it's not that great
you get a dollar slice in new york yeah
it is foolish of me to act like knowing
it was one dollar didn't contribute to
my enjoyment of that yeah of course but
it was amazing you don't go to a new
york pizza place and be like i would
like an exquisite meal right now please
one dollar oh what a steal is it because
stone bay pizzas are not big enough
that is one big factor is that it yeah
it's not okay so
so hypothetically if you found a
restaurant here in japan or wherever
that does stone-baked sourdough pizza
but it was the size of a new york pizza
but also they skimp out on the toppings
a lot right no i mean the problem with
in japan they definitely do but if
you've had if you've had like stone bait
in england like in europe and a lot of
the time they skimp out they're like i'm
like you don't put enough toppings on
there's not like there's like the sauce
is generous enough i'd say but like
cheese like come on man you know i i had
stones in italy and they stacked that
[ __ ] because i haven't i haven't been to
italy but like the best stone baked
pizzas places i go to they don't skimp
on the cheese they don't scream pound
the toppings because you're in like a
british british version of it so they're
like they fix it
[Music]
the one i had in northern italy was
packed was it really yeah it was like
every time i've had one in italy it's
it's been like
like very lacking in toppings really
yeah and i think you're going to the
right places yeah i don't know like and
like as the person who is like the
biggest simp for bread like how does
that not play a factor in how these
pizzas taste oh so that's more of a i
would say stone baked in many aspects in
my mind it's more about enjoying the
bread than it is about the pizza like i
don't even consider it like right right
to a point where i'm like it's flavored
bread i'd rather just get like bread
like at this point you know just give me
the give me a real [ __ ] pizza bro if
it doesn't give me like five spots the
next day it isn't a pizza bro i want to
be [ __ ] up
[ __ ] me up with this pizza
you know what you know what the world's
right british people don't have taste no
i'm just like you know what's confirmed
i'm too american with this one man
i'm american all the way on this one
from american pizza it goes hard it
doesn't it doesn't look like there's a
there's a time and a place for an
american pizza every time hands down
every day there is there is a time and a
place for american pizza but every day
it is not the superior people it is not
the city it is not the superior period
sir america i salute you with your pizza
okay then your pizza slaps keep doing it
okay let's see how okay then question
which one's better japanese sushi or
american sushi right
well no obviously like japan does it
better
well then sushi yeah yeah so like would
you if if if i was to give you a choice
of like just standard like nikon of like
just regular tuna that you get like a
cup position here or california raw
which one would you shoot but i feel
like comparing like i feel like at the
end of the day a pizza a stone baked
pizza and a pizza are like the same [ __ ]
right what you've said but like like
the a sushi roll is not even remotely
like sushi come on you cannot see me
dead in the eye
okay connor what you've basically said
yeah like is basically like oh yeah
sweet and sour chicken is the best
chinese food
you know orange chicken
orange orange chicken is the best
chicken tikka
and listen to this [ __ ] okay i've
had okay right i've had both both i'll
become an honorary italian for like a
[ __ ]
you guys have [ __ ] pizza compared to the
americans come on
i just i just can't get over the fact
let's trace it back to
you know it's like with sushi and stuff
like that there's like a lot of the like
the sushi is not even close i don't even
think that's how is it all close it's a
same ingredient
no it's not yeah a lot of the time the
ingredients aren't even similar
everything inside of a california roll
they use in regular sushi here they look
really just not together what's in the
california room
california what are the ingredients of
california
it's salmon you sounded so confident
it's salmon cucumber yeah
well rosie
but japan has roles as well
do they really yeah no but they don't
have the same kind of role not the same
kind of fried [ __ ] right no no no no no
no no nothing like from what i've seen
japan japanese rolls are just like one
fish in a row and that feels like that's
it yeah right like this is a dumb
argument but i'm ready to die for it
okay that's trash taste there right yeah
okay it ain't a food
i'm watching a man commit suicide and
i'm just like all right connor you jump
off the cliff
don't don't say i didn't try to like
grab you and warn you that you this is a
cliff you're jumping off i think a lot
of the viewers will agree with me that
american pizza is better than italian
first of all we have american audience
it's yeah and it's because i guarantee
that there are more americans watching
this than italians and there are more
people who have been to america than
italy
i've been to both
yes yes yes ashley yes
california roll is not japanese yeah i
know we know yeah yeah
what are the ingredients these are the
imitation crab
which they have
which they have you'll get crab on sushi
normally though really yeah of course
you do not that often i get all the time
really well i've never seen in any sushi
train you get like the crab head in the
thing but you never get like crap you
can crab on it yeah you can really you
ever seen this yes the man who just said
that meat sushi didn't exist even though
he's had it so you know
to this day i still don't view it when i
go to get sushi no he's not exactly the
most reliable narrator this man
doesn't matter america pizza is better
than stone baked i'll die on the hill oh
my god this is just like uh the a bad
person making a good argument like
people just gonna disagree with me
because i'm [ __ ] dumb it's not a good
argument it's a great answer it's not a
great argument
it's quite in fact the opposite you're a
good person with a [ __ ] this is a
preferential thing i just think the
pizza is better it's not flat out not
saying okay look i'm not saying american
pizza is bad i love this this is not
what we are doing both pizzas are
fantastic right in their own unique
place like it is so far beyond belief to
even insist that america pizza could be
interpreted as better than stone baked
you mean like that's just a wild clay
it's not wild
people like american pizza more than
stone babies because they've never had
stone baked they have had stone bags
i remember
i want to see how many people i think
you'll be shocked by the amount of
viewers that actually think america i
want to set up how many people how many
of our viewers who have had both can
agree with you and say that the
americans your head your head's in the
cloud would you would you say domino's
is better than stone bay pizza then
in my in my mind i would rather a
domino's pizza than stone baked pizza
and i have seen right i remember i
remember as well i thought i felt so
gratify like like hey i'll get this man
some taste buds i felt i felt so
relieved
who's that guy who's like 1500 netflix
shows the uh i think he's a chef from uh
i think japan but he's he's american the
bearded guy yeah yeah i forgot his name
there was like one one scene right where
he was doing a whole thing about pizza
and he went around reviewing all
different types of pizza and there's one
time one scene where he's like you know
at the end of the day though there's
just something about a domino's pizza
that'll just go so hard and i was like
yes yes that's probably a reason why we
don't remember his name pretending like
domino's pizza or these like fast food
pizzas taste like [ __ ] you just clean i
never said that we never said we never
said that it's it's like it's like
saying a mcdonald's burger is better
than like a gourmet freshly made burger
at a burger joint you know like yes
there's a place for it but to to say
that is better is like i've had many
burgers where i would prefer the
mcdonald's burger over said burger well
yes of course because a lot of the time
they're just like yeah let's just get
some like good beef i should like not
consider the ratios or anything let's
put like [ __ ] let's put like 500 no no
what i'm saying what the argument we're
making is think of the best burger
you've ever had that wasn't mcdonald's
and put that next to a mcdonald's burger
which one would you like i've had a lot
of pizza uh in italy that wasn't stone
baked that i think was much better than
stone baked
there was more yeah
i mean weird style it's like it's like
the heaviness of it yeah stone baked
isn't the only type of pizza but to me
definitely it is like the pinnacle i i
[ __ ] i [ __ ] love stone cakes
it's the best bread and you know what
it's because it's like the best bread
the best cheese used to come from a man
who can't appreciate the crust like this
comes from like i feel like you've
already tasted the pizza it's because
[ __ ] tastes like because i don't eat the
crust that i can appreciate a [ __ ]
good stone break because it's the only
pizza that i eat the crust okay you have
like it's like watching a veganated
chicken wing it's like oh my god there's
a monument it must be a really [ __ ]
good chicken you don't even appreciate
bread so how can you even have an
opinion on what's better pizza like you
know what i mean like you don't have a
coffee no no no it's it's like i don't
appreciate 90 percent of bread because
to me 90 percent of bread taste the
[ __ ] same you know that's but it's
like when i i'm afraid i don't have to
get you to stop writing you cannot say i
was on your side until you said that
that's like that's like me going bro
every [ __ ] rice and noodle is the
[ __ ] same yeah like it's like that's
just yeah udon is exactly the same as
the little bro it's like no different
from instant noodles both ninety
percent's the same okay it's like ninety
percent of the ramen noodles i didn't
think you could be racist towards white
people but in that moment i think you
genuinely were i think that was actually
racist towards white people bro french
people clutching their baguettes right
now french bro germans are losing it
right now that's half of german food man
dude
we got to do a trash taste special we
just take gantt to a german bakery and
he just is like what the [ __ ] i don't
know you could have 15 different types
are you saying okay yeah are you saying
that a pretzel tastes the same as a
baguette
it's pretzel bread oh what's going on
this is bread
not the little [ __ ] hard like
cookie-esque ones like like bristles a
pretzel yeah all right i'm gonna be
honest okay what are you about to say
i'm gonna be honest
a pretzel to me is just a salted
paquette
that's what that's what it tastes like
to me
right that's that's kind of what it
tastes like to me okay
like to me to me bread
okay to me like to me i can't i can't
eat this that's how world war three
began to me i can't eat bread by itself
a lot of times it needs to be flavored
okay it needs to have some butter on it
like for example a baguette i need some
butter with that baguette a lot of the
times okay pretzels they have salt okay
no you can't just eat a baguette like a
good baguette with butter no just a
bigger just eat a bite i can't [ __ ]
hear but get by itself
that's just like you've just lost all
your weight this episode gone you like
won the italians and then threw them
away
what the [ __ ] god even the attacker
even the italians are doing this right
how can you go on a european tournament
[ __ ] action
okay with the crust you know with the
crust you're not eating you know it's
not like you have the pizza part with
the cheese and you know and the toppings
and everything and then you have the
crust part right that's a very small
ratio to the whole pizza itself i can't
eat a pizza sized crust no matter how
good like the [ __ ] stone baked crust
i can just chow down on the whole
baguette like strawberry
genuinely yeah i think you if you if you
had fresh bread like good bread i think
you'd change your fresh bread is good
but like like not like [ __ ] tesco
bread no no no no no i've i've had fresh
bread but bread to me it's like fresh
bread i'm i'm skeptical now where have
you had this fresh bread okay so you you
go you
you had fresh bread yesterday no that
was that was [ __ ] great could i eat
more than just the slice that we got no
that was that was too much and with the
slice you know i i [ __ ] i gotta
destroy that whole plate i cannot i
can't yeah i could have had that that's
like wait every time i go to an italian
restaurant
i've had many meals which i've enjoyed
the bread like an amount where honestly
if the rest of my food didn't come out i
would be happy every time i go to an
italian restaurant in america and they
always give you that like the plate of
bread i'm just like more i need more
this is not gonna be enough bread to me
is a starter it is a starter it is not
the meal you can't just have bread as a
meal this man would not know who i'm
offending with this take right now but
to me like the entire middle ages i
can't just have peasants in the 1800s
pure bread as a meal i'm pretty sure
like if you were born in the 1700s in
europe you would be so dead i didn't
think we're going to have enough
dinner
you guys made such you guys made such a
big [ __ ] deal about this pizza thing
that i didn't think was a big
deal man walks in here being like bread
is [ __ ] okay okay like straight up like
what like you don't even have like a
gluten allergy or something or something
[ __ ] like that to like behind but i
didn't say bread was [ __ ] i said bread
is not a meal he said 90 of bread and i
quote taste the same okay
okay i'm gonna go back on that statement
okay
ninety percent of spread does not taste
the same how many percent huh how much
percent but i mean like 87
with bread i can't have bread as a meal
that's like having pure rice as a meal
okay no
as an asian i can't just have rice as a
meal i know people can just have rice as
a meal but you need some stuff you need
some [ __ ] seasoning on the rice you
know you need some flavoring you need
something to go with the rice i can have
rice as a meal yeah i know you can but i
know i know you can but
bread doesn't fill the same like role as
rice right it literally does no it does
literally no it doesn't it doesn't yeah
i mean like i i'll completely disagree
that all bread tastes the same or
whatever but i can agree that all rice
tastes the same yes okay i i would i
would say most right really yeah really
that is that is there is different types
of rice yeah yeah but yeah like
obviously i can tell the difference
between like japanese rice and like
saffron but it's like rice pudding and
all that [ __ ] as well that's all
nonsense
i mean is rice pudding even rice said
that that's the point comparing the
roles that bread and rice phil is like
no it's completely different it's
totally different i can't believe you
you're japanese joey you're going to say
that all rice tastes the same where a
huge part of japanese cuisine is like
the subtle differences in how the rice
tastes hey yo that's all [ __ ]
every time you go to a [ __ ] gyokan or
anything and you get like the massive
meal and they bring out the [ __ ] bowl
of rice and it's like this is the this
is the top branded rice of this
prefecture and i take a bite and i'm
like bro this tastes like you are wrong
it does not taste it tastes exactly the
same
you're chowing down on it too [ __ ]
fast to appreciate the subtle [ __ ]
taste it's literally just carbs it's
just that's what bread is that's what
bread is literally just calves it's
literally just carbs it's so much more
than that whereas rice is just pure
starch right bread has so much more that
goes into making a good bread right
you've got all the different ingredients
anymore right rice is just like 100
starch right no because there is subtle
differences into how to cook
but no no rice like if someone if if we
brought out two bowls of rice right and
one was from like [ __ ] you know octa
prefecture
i could not tell you the [ __ ] no it's
not just about the type of rice it's how
you cook it as well which is why you
know sushi rice tastes different
depending on which sushi place you go to
because sushi rice tastes different
because it's got vinegar in it no but
that that it's cooked with vinegar it's
seasoned with vinegar yeah obviously
yeah so it's part of the cooking process
but if
two if there was two bowls of sushi rice
one from akhtar and one from nagano you
can't tell the difference that's like
saying if two pieces of bread were
cooked exactly the same then they you
know then they taste the same which they
would because they cooked exactly the
same way
that's
i feel like both of these arguments are
[ __ ] stupid yeah they are
i just realized both arguments here i
just realized i'm losing my brain
i'm losing my mind in this [ __ ]
conversation now
i i think i i do agree though rice is
less uh what's the word diverse diverse
than bread like the bread has
way too many i'm saying but like my core
argument is that i can't eat bread as a
meal it's the same way
that's the same way as eating rices and
i genuinely believe you haven't had good
bread like genuinely i have had good i
don't think you had was the bread we had
yesterday good that was even compared to
german bread that's mid
was that was it good bread yesterday i
thought it was kind of good it was good
it was good it was good right don't get
me wrong it was good bread but i'm
telling you man i i i've been i've never
been to germany so i don't know like
yeah i spent a lot of a lot of my
childhood in germany and i can tell you
man it's [ __ ] good it's so good like
every time i go to german restaurant
it's like amazing because it's like the
only thing that germany does well right
is the three foods that german like
specialize in beer which is food there
it's not a drink it's food
you have bread and then you have meat
like just the meat is good right
sausages right right yeah [ __ ]
amazing yeah right great sausages and
there's a reason why they stick to three
things because they [ __ ] do it
amazing the bread is insane everyone's
like french baguettes no french
baguettes can like [ __ ] themselves bro
german bread is like 20 000 light years
ahead right of it it's it's not even
comparable so could you what if you
could have bread as a meal why don't you
then you're saying you're on variation
right you want like different things
like if you just have bread every day
yeah you'll get bored but i can easily
have bread occasionally as a full meal
if i needed to really if i if it was
german bread yeah no qualms about it
yeah of course german bread like a fresh
pretzel yeah if you give me like three
brittles just by itself not like no no
mustard or anything give me a beer too
give me a beer with that i need i need a
stronger taste than just bread you know
because you haven't had good bread you
haven't had i have a good product
no matter how good the bread is i can't
eat a bread as an entirely new we're
going to do you know we're going to have
anything in germany get a good breakfast
i can appreciate good breads you know i
can appreciate a good slice before the
actual meal comes out before before the
actual serving of whatever dish i've
ordered comes out you know bread is a
good starter gets you know gets the
palette going but can i eat an entire if
i go to a restaurant and i'm like you're
lucky
not a german job i'll tell you that
waiter i would like to order an entire
plate of bread and nothing else i'm just
like no i i can't do that that's why you
get a bakery you go to the restaurant
first yeah that's what amazing there's a
thing called a bakery that serves
exclusively
you're like cut out the middle man know
it's like it's like made for people who
want bread as a meal perhaps you know
oh my god
you exhausted now gone i am exhausted i
can't wait for this [ __ ] hot dog for
us to turn on i i want to i want to try
this [ __ ] dude yeah i really want to try
this [ __ ] this episode is sponsored by
boxer ho ho ho merry boxue christmas
gamers here's one for you joey here's
one for you guns oh my god it truly is a
magical time to be alive but sansa could
you explain to us what these
boxes are why yes of course joey i can
box use a monthly snack box description
service that delivers original
assortments of premium japanese snacks
and tea pairings box makes such a
perfect and memorable gift for anyone in
your life who appreciates japanese
snacks and culture especially during a
time where people aren't able to travel
as easy as they would like and something
special for all the amazing boxu
customers this holiday season they will
get free tickets to japan maybe are you
serious maybe boxing is having a
giveaway where one lucky winner will win
a free pair of tickets to japan and
anyone who is subscribed before december
31st it's automatically entered links in
the description down below so you can
check out the terms and conditions and
other methods of entry gentlemen do you
like wood i do because here's a wooden
kitty buckle boxu just for you guys oh
my god look at that look how aesthetic
this is
from now until december 30th you can
receive your next box suit in a special
kiribaku wooden box for an additional 50
so use our code trash test 10 and the
link in the description below to become
eligible to win the giveaway by
subscribing to boxxu the co will get you
ten percent off your subscription don't
miss out on this unique opportunity
available for anyone who subscribes
until december 31st so what are you
waiting for get yourself or a special
loved one at kiribati boxu and check out
the link for a chance to win a free trip
to japan back to the episode also i just
want to say
that you said every beer even no matter
or beer bread where it's like you make
it it'll taste the same you could have
the same ingredients actually it's been
proven
that when an air like bread rises the
air surrounding it depending on the
region completely changes oh
shut the hell up
can we put this in the episode sydney
you meant to be on my side
sydney put it in and then you justice
has been served can't believe i've got
been betrayed by this
sydney we're meant to be a [ __ ] team
top 10 anime betrayal
no because then you're also saying like
you guys saying like rice tastes the
same like what kind of [ __ ] like
honestly no rice does taste the same
rice does taste the same it doesn't
taste the same
complete difference between thai rice
japanese rice no no no no but all right
all japanese rice tastes the same no but
all rice does not taste the same it does
all japanese rice tastes the same yeah
uh all japanese rice tastes the same you
guys are fooling yourselves it all
tastes like it's all a marketing ploy
it's all a marketing ploy don't believe
that [ __ ] when they tell you at the
ryokan they could be giving you [ __ ]
100 yen like microwave package rice for
all i care yeah but while we were
waiting for the hot dog crust i do have
a story go on uh that finishes the uh
the lasagna arc the the lasagna story
arc well it's not it's not even like a
it's like a side story now yeah yeah so
after our housewarming party
um you know we we got a pretty merry and
there was one thing i had forgotten
about japan because in my previous place
i lived on like a high enough floor that
i didn't need to worry about bugs or
wildlife or that kind of thing because
uh because you know nothing could ever
reach yeah reach the top floor of my
apartment at the time
so i forgot that uh japan has
cockroaches
right i sure do guys
i had completely forgotten that japan
had cockroaches right and
what we found out was uh during the
party we didn't close one of like our
windows fully so the window was slightly
ajar and we had left the food out
because
um unlike in thailand where we were
taught to you know clean up everything
every day because cockroaches can come
living in a house we had forgotten that
cockroaches can come because we are
living on the bottom floor yeah where a
lot of cockroaches are unfortunately i
mean it's a pretty new house so we
didn't have any we didn't have to worry
about that before um and i didn't notice
this or i didn't know this
until me and sydney were having dinner
the next day you know we kicked a nice
meal sydney had kicked a nice meal um
and we were enjoying this curry that she
had cooked and we were like chowing down
um and then i look over and in the
corner of my eye i see a black speck
move about right and i and i move over
and i look over and there's a fat
[ __ ] cockroach
how fat are we talking it's it's it's
about it's about that size okay that's
pretty easy that's a decent size it's
it's a it's a decent it's a decent-sized
cotton crush moved in yeah i i had just
moved in and i literally got i i i got
ptsd because if if if you don't remember
i had had a previous experience with a
cockroach in thailand the famous
cockroach yeah if uh if you want to
check that out there's a clip where i
tell the story but i i had had a
previous experience with thailand in
thailand with a cockroach um and it
wasn't a pleasant experience at all
right and i remember seeing this
cockroach and sydney was like see sydney
was like chatting away to me and uh she
was like gone
gone and i just like i was just silent i
was just staring at this cockroach
and then she she like starts getting
angry go on listen to me and before and
she says that and then she looks over
and then we're just both staring in
silence and then and then it's as if the
cockroach knew that we were looking at
it it was it was it was flexing because
we lo as soon as sydney looked over it
just crawls away into the air
conditioning in one of the holes and it
just disappears
and we and me and sydney are just like
[ __ ]
how do we burn this entire house down we
can't burn this entire house down we
just [ __ ] moved into this place right
the cockroach literally did an
understandable habitat
and discovery and me and sydney were
just sitting here in silence we were
like war veterans right because we were
just like we we literally escaped again
yeah we literally escaped this country
uh we literally escaped thailand so we
didn't have to experience this again
yeah and here we are moved into our new
place where it's we've been here for
like a month and we have a single
cockroach in our house
[ __ ] what do we do so um
so we sit there for about an hour being
like
well do we move out again um is is that
a viable option like how how what does
the contract say right and then
eventually i'm just like i started going
on amazon and i buy like every cockroach
related
um products i can find in terms of like
cockroach traps cockroach sprays even
though i've had previous experience with
cockroach phrase i started really never
works i start reading
some of the [ __ ] are built like brick
[ __ ] yeah you could put the whole thing
if terraformers have taught us anything
that [ __ ] don't work yeah they are
invincible yeah so like i started doing
research about japanese cockroaches and
you know if sprays actually work or if
traps actually works because um
my experience with cockroaches in
thailand is that sprays don't work at
[ __ ] all and uh it can actually make
the situation worse yeah um and just
like scream yeah they just they just
scream they're gonna go in
yeah and so that was so i order
everything and i just try to forget
about the cockroach but like but like
that night me and sydney slept with like
one eye open like we could we couldn't
sleep that night because we were just
like how can we sleep knowing that there
is a [ __ ] cockroach
downstairs you know what what happens if
i go to the toilet and i see it or i
just hear it scuffling about you know
like so dark yeah so in the dark so
so uh we finally go to sleep and then
first thing in the morning i go
downstairs to go to my office because my
office is on the bottom floor and my
living room dining room is on the second
floor
um and i go downstairs and what do i see
it's the [ __ ] it's right in the center
of my living room it's got a lot of
balls
it has got a lot of balls right on the
kitchen and i [ __ ] freeze up i'm just
like [ __ ]
how do i get rid of this cockroach what
would i do now i don't have my spray i
don't like i don't know i'm kind of
scared that it's just gonna like run off
maybe it's gonna fly and like like me in
the face again like maybe it's going to
be my similar experience to what
happened in thailand yeah i'm getting
out the shoes yeah yeah
i'm getting it yeah and i and i'm just
like i don't understand
yeah i'm like i'm like looking around
what do i do do i do i try and kill it
do i chase it away what do i do and then
i like trying to like ninja my way down
right and as soon as i try to do that it
sees me and then it starts running right
it starts running and then i look at it
and i realize wait a minute this is it's
running so [ __ ] slowly because my my
experience was with thailand cockroaches
is that like they're like [ __ ] sonic
they're like [ __ ] like speedy
[ __ ] this cockroach is running
at full speed and it was just running
like this
and i'm like and and then and then i
like i corner it so it runs the other
way because i'm still afraid that he can
fly and i chase it towards the stairs
right and i assume that it's just gonna
get to the stairs and fly off it it goes
to the edge of the stairs right and this
stupid [ __ ] right it it tries to
go on the side of the stairs and it just
drops
right it just drops right and i'm just
like wait a minute these [ __ ] can't
fly
they can't fly and they're slow as [ __ ]
and then suddenly i'm like i'm starting
to feel myself i'm like all right all
right maybe i got a chance here maybe i
don't need the cockroach spray i can get
rid of this by myself so eventually like
this the cockroach right now is on the
bottom floor so it's like it just it's
it's not even flying it didn't even like
fly down it just like it just walked to
the edge of the stairs stumbled down
like landed on his back
like uh went downstairs and they kept
going downstairs so
i run down the stairs and i go into my
office and i try to grab the closest
thing i could find to like [ __ ] slam
this thing right and so by the closest
thing i could find in this rush happened
to be
a mouse pad
a booby mouse pad right
what is that gonna do why i don't you
literally could have got anything else i
think your fist would have been more of
like yeah okay because i did i didn't i
didn't want to i didn't want to like i
didn't want to stain myself okay so
there's going to stay in the booby mouth
yeah yeah okay we used to crying right
it was the it was the fastest thing i
could find in the rush
this thing you can find do you guys
because i was looking for something like
a shoe or something but everything in my
office like i can't i can't grab it is
it in your office right next to where
you keep your shoes
um so my shoes were like in the cupboard
right so about the slam dunk shoes
usually
i am not
so like most of the things in my office
like figures or most of the things i see
like figures or like glass or like like
solid [ __ ] so the only thing that was
like i felt that you know was close the
closest nasty city yeah elasticity the
best thing i could like slam this thing
without having to worry about it
breaking happened to be the booby
mousepad right
why was that i wasn't thinking okay
there's nothing else in your room is
this the domestic girlfriend one that
you got yeah oh no
okay so this is my [ __ ] signed piece
of memorabilia it wasn't signed it
wasn't signed i i have my signed piece
of memory it was the worst girl yeah
yeah so so okay so this was just like i
explained this like i thought about this
consciously no i just ran in my room
just like grabs grab this mouse pad that
was the closest thing and just ran back
out and um by instinct or maybe not by
instinct so i grabbed like the booby
side of things right
i grabbed the tit side of things right
and but like this this mouse pad it's
like you've you felt like a blue mouse
pad it's flimsy but it still has like
some weight to it right so it's not
exactly like it's i'm hitting it with
paper it has like a little bit of weight
but it's like it's like it's like
slapping someone like that i failed to
see how you you picked this up you're
like yes this
is
dancing like the [ __ ] gladiator
stadium like gonz you may choose a
weapon of your choice picks up a rock
picks up the booby mouse pad i'm ready
look i had picked it up i had committed
to whip because i was scared that i
would run back out and the cockroach
would be gone right but i thankfully i
ran back out it was still there i'm like
great i [ __ ] wham it once okay we're
at full strength slap it doesn't do
anything yeah yeah yeah yeah you hit it
with makes it like an air cannon yeah so
i so so i'm just like whammy ones didn't
work whammy twice didn't work so i'm
just like [ __ ]
like i don't like like
[ __ ] quentin tarantino scene honestly
it was it was like you know it was like
a scene from a gangster movie or
something he said like i don't have a
hammer i'm not bashing someone's head in
i'm bashing this [ __ ] cockroach in
with like with a movie booby mousepad
and like this thing okay so i hit it it
it like falls over runs back again
flips over runs back again
but like after after about after about
five slams it starts slowing down this
thing was like [ __ ] boss battle yeah
it had like a [ __ ] health bar right
but like i could see his health bar like
he's whistling down right sydney's like
gone what's going on god i don't say
anything i need to concentrate on
keeping silence
all i hear is the bottom of this all i
hear is the [ __ ] dark souls boss
battle music i like i like i go for it
for another like three times it's like
it's like crawling now but i still can't
i still can't do the finishing like the
i can't i still can't deal the finishing
blow so i'm just like finally after it
starts crawling i start using my head
i'm like wait a minute this isn't the
heavy side i thought you made like
literally like
what's harder than a movie mouse yeah
i was like wait a minute this isn't the
heavy side so i'm like all right i'm
going to do the finishing move i turn
the mouse back over so it's booby side
up that's this is where all the weight
is right i go for one more [ __ ] wham
direct hit one hit kill it is dead right
it is
he literally went from like
he went from dual blade to a broad suit
i don't know if you're framing this
story like some kind of victory it
sounds like the most pathetic thing i've
ever heard
because
when it's like when i saw it belly up
right i literally was like panting right
that's the soft spot
i was like ah
sydney runs down right she's like
panicking because she thought i just
fell down the [ __ ] stairs or
something because she all she heard was
like wham wham and me just like heavy
breathing and
all sydney witnesses it's just me
standing over the standing over the dead
corpse of this cockroach with like a
booby mouse pad in her in hand and i'm
just like
in my mind i was like do you see what
you get
do you see what you get
so like that's how i felt i've never
felt so much
i just want to know why was the
cockroach like
i don't think i've ever said like heard
of a cockroach be that i've seen maybe
it hates so much lasagna oh there are
some slow cockroaches
it ate the lasagna probably
i was like oh [ __ ] i'm so full all right
i'm just going to stop doing this
well i mean you probably have more huh
that means you probably have more no i
mean we already saw one and we've only
seen it all you only saw one but you
know these sneaky [ __ ] they've
probably created a club
we've gotta we've got a load of traps
out just in case you know and uh i've
been dealing with a pest of my own what
that sounds like i was gonna say like
yeah
um
[ __ ] pigeons keep [ __ ] on my
balcony oh really yeah
and i because i put like the grass down
they keep [ __ ] on the grass
it's sure how hard it is to clean fake
grass that's so it because like you
you've seen my balcony yeah sorry
i was gonna ask how do you not get
pigeon [ __ ] on your butt never they
come here they chill there i'll
literally i'll clean it all up right
it'll take like 30 minutes to clean all
this [ __ ] up there's so much crap the
only place actually that i get pigeons
is the window in my office which is like
on the edge of the building i think
because there's like it my balcony is
like in wood so it's like there's no
like wind or anything right right i
think it's like nice and cozy for them
because they always go for like the
corner top like they nestle in a corner
yeah yeah yeah yeah and they they [ __ ]
on this thing relentlessly i'll
literally clean it and i'll come back
the next day and i'll be like 15 poops
and it's it's annoying because it's like
solidifying you need to have something
to like like anti-pigeon so now i've
started having to i've gone through like
every method in the book i've got like
reflective [ __ ] all over my balcony now
right right it's just hanging up cds
like yeah stuff that reflects in so far
so far it's working no poop oh that's
good so i'm hoping that i don't get any
more poop good just remembering that
story is just getting me aggie man sorry
i didn't realize
how relentless these pigeons could be
right and they're so noisy too yeah i'll
be sleeping i got my ptsd
and i'm like
[ __ ] don't get out of here damn kids
pulls out the shotgun off my loans i get
god's m16 from the the
figure episode
who wants some freedom but yeah i didn't
use the m16 on the the cockroach the m16
is here oh you should take it
if we ever get a cockroach
yeah m16 resting on his uh his shoulder
i dare you i dare you to take another
bite of lasagna cockroach i dare you no
no because because after after uh after
we uh killed it or after i killed it you
know
yeah
this is not a wee thing
after our victory after right after i
killed it you know after i successfully
like slayed this [ __ ] demon
then like she finally her like [ __ ]
lisa playing in the background
after i slay this demon we get we got
like we got this uh was it we got the
brush out we sweep it sweep it away
right yeah so i take it outside
lay it out turns out the boss had like a
second had like a second phase it
[ __ ] gets up again right the undead
phase
oh the old classic played the old
classic it's so weird because like when
we were sweeping in no movement [ __ ]
dead as soon as it goes outside that's a
pro right there as soon as it goes
outside turns over starts scuttling away
so i had to like [ __ ] hit it again
hit it again with what huh with the
broom with the broom right but if it's
outside then just leave it right you
know no it's it's not it's not all about
it's about sending it's about sending a
message you need to send a message
the kids are watching yeah yeah
yeah but then eventually i'm just like
[ __ ] it you know i'm gonna let this one
go i'll be like tell your friends tell
your friends what happens if you enter
this house you know
come again i did
come again and that was how gantt became
a local hero yeah exactly all right the
uh the hot dog pizza has arrived do you
know how much it was we've received
about 2 200. [ __ ] 22 bucks for a pizza
this size look at this oh it's it's 50
off though this was 20 dollars
thanks japan thank you [ __ ] what what
a joke look at that
oh my god it's like actual like sausages
yeah bro dig in all right digging on
what kind of pizza is it just a normal
margarita no it's a pepperoni yeah give
me a slice there we go you're not going
to tell me that this is better than
stone baked oh there this is bro okay to
be fair i can't moist that i'm not i'm
not a massive fan of pizza hut pizza in
japan no the pizza it's this okay this
this one in japan is weak yeah
not great but i am curious to see how
this uh yeah how this sausage is going
to fare
hmm that's pretty good actually yeah
i mean pizza is pizza so it's going to
taste good no matter what um i just have
that thick cheesy taste you know that's
thick bread um
i apologize what point were we trying to
prove again the hot dog i mean when you
get to it try it okay
and then like wrap it up a little bit
get some sauce i just eat it first i
feel like it's going to taste less good
than that pizza side i've got a bit of
sauce left some cheese on it
[Music]
it's such a honey pot it's a hot dog i
love it
okay i'll [ __ ] with this right isn't it
good it's weirdly good right
i mean i've had this before it shouldn't
be this good like i normally get dip as
well oh but is this is this better than
stuffed crust yeah i think so i think
it's better than stuff crosstalk they're
so good
i love that i don't like the cheese
they're using stuffed crust
really yeah it's too like um thick yeah
it's weighted and it's like it like it
tastes like very similar so you just get
like a lot of cheese like way too much
no yeah you have to have like the fresh
stuff crossed because when it starts
later when it starts off please try give
us your verdict give it a go
give us a go sausage we need a second
opinion on this when it starts to harden
a bit that's when stuff crusts i don't
like starch why is it what is it like
outside well normally sometimes it's
inside but i like it i think it's good
yeah i want sydney's voting because an
american
yeah sydney what's what's your verdict
as an american sydney let's try it
well just just eat it just just eat it
how you normally would and then when you
get to the cross just like leave a
little bit of the pizza yeah and then
just go from the side john's like left
on his pizza can you please oh we did it
later i died [ __ ] you
i'll finish it later who just leaves the
pizza for america i'm not that hungry
i'll be what am i american
i'm not american but god damn sometimes
i wish i was maybe that's why i'm so
angry about them all the time because i
i just want to be an american maybe
i wish he was angry at something he
can't be i just i wish i could be
american honest opinion well it's an
option i mean it's fine it's with dip
it's way better like maybe
when you get some dip on it man it's it
oh yeah is it optional
if you put something like if you put
some ranch on that [ __ ] oh my god bro
it's different oh
something
no i'd rather cheese in a crust okay
okay
i would i would prefer cheese in the
crust as well it's like you get a pizza
and then at the end you're like oh [ __ ]
you get like a little meal at the end
yeah okay
i like it i like it i never i'd never go
to a restaurant and look look a waiter
in the eye and be like can i have the
option with the hot dog in the class but
if i can if i can call up a pizza place
and tell them hey can you send it with
the cr for some reason
i think i've figured out your taste
which is you need some like variety in
it you can't just have like even if
something tastes amazing you can't just
have that same thing no i mean i i can
eat bread like straight up just say that
except for bread apparently yeah it's
it's like two ends of the spectrum
there's either no variety or too much
variety this is what half and half is
amazing as well like i love half and
half like who doesn't want half and half
i don't know one half i don't like half
and half i don't like why would you not
want like two different flavors because
because because why not why not just
order the superior flavor yeah and just
stick on the two flavors are amazing and
i want to experience both
one one flavor is always the best so i
ordered that flavor yeah and that's all
i need because
i agree because because like because if
you have half an hour half and half
never very rarely
never by choice it's always at a party
right because you need variety at a
party right yeah but like i often find
that halfway through a pizza especially
a heavy one i kind of need something
else to kind of mix it up so that i'm
not tasting just the same same same same
thing but that's what dip is for right
yeah well different i mean i love dip
too when i have pizza i want like every
dip on the table like yeah and i'm like
dunk dunk exactly well for me if i have
the same thing but it's an amazing same
thing then i can just eat that endlessly
until i'm sure but because pizza is like
that style of pizza we just had is quite
heavy like getting four or five slices
of that in you're like all right i need
a chicken no it's not
stone babies yeah yeah yeah but i'm not
i'm not saying that stone baked is is
like
better it's like god was waiting for him
now is the time to strike that's right
if you fold up a stone baked pizza into
one into like one little ball it's like
one slice of a normal american pizza and
dinner what
do you fold up your pizza into a bowl
yo could we do that can we roll up a
stone-baked pizza into a bowl and just
like take a bite out of it it's like
kind of wrap it around yeah yeah it's
just like turning it's like a dim sum
yeah yeah like a dim sum yeah it's like
wrapping it around
i think
i'm like i'm just speechless i think i
actually got the italian mafia on me for
saying that you just lost any right to
go to italy yeah i can't i think we've
all lost some sort of right to some sort
of uh
i mean yes you have yeah yes you are
yeah you have definitely really just i'm
pretty sure you just declared war
against italy i'm i'm willing to give
credit where credit to italy you know
create a way credit is due to italy like
like they were the ones that kind of
came in and was like you guys have it
good
right
british man
all right hear me out right
let me out here the italians are gone
coffee they're doing that right
they got something right you know
pasta all right they got that on
lockdown no no one can even pretend to
have like any claim over here
okay yeah so like okay for example right
like american pasta is like a little bit
different to like the standard italian
pasta right italian pasta is like
[ __ ] drenched in uh sorry uh um
american is like [ __ ] heavy it's like
so much sauce like that's a lot of oil
yeah okay i don't [ __ ] with that that's
just too much yeah it has a time in
place yeah yeah like like a magiano's is
like every now and then i'll go there if
i want to feel like i want to destroy my
stomach yeah like i understand how olive
garden can do like bottomless of stuff
like oh it's the way they do bottomless
bread down there yeah it's bottomless
breast sticks yeah that's true which is
like the bird sticks aren't even that
good
it's like i don't want bottomless or
something that's mid would you have a
entire an entire meal of breadsticks it
depends how good the best breadsticks
are good
not all of garden bread sticks though no
that's just like bread flavored
cardboard
sorry i'll have gone but
i'm just i'm just wondering when we
ordered um we ordered uh it was napoleon
style pizza from around uh not too far
away there's a few chains of them around
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
and it was awful oh yeah yeah really
[ __ ] it wasn't that great they're so bad
yeah well i mean it's japan right and i
don't even know that i was going for
like that was going for like stone baked
but not stone baked that was a really
weird hybrid remember that it was like
it looked like it looked like a stone
bake but it didn't taste like it was
actually yeah
yeah
it's like it's like it looks stone-baked
but here's an oven
a lot of pizzas i find don't have a very
discernible cheesy taste and i l i want
to be able to taste the cheese right
yeah same that like a lot of pizzas
either either because that's also when
you put too much topping on the pizza
yeah yeah like you can't taste anything
because you taste like meat
it's too much i need to taste all the
flavors in unison yeah yeah
so like
there needs to be like a right ratio of
like crust yeah sauce and cheese and
toppings as well yeah exactly
otherwise otherwise
there are some pizzas i see where like
it's basically just you know cheesy
bread and
i know that's a type of pizza i'm gonna
get a pizza that's just cheese right oh
and you can also get margaritas and
cheese pizza yeah which is just which is
just uh sauce yeah cheese yeah yeah i
don't understand the [ __ ] with that yeah
i don't [ __ ] with that i don't get that
i guess that's if you're like i want to
have a pizza but i don't i don't feel
too bad about it it's like the people
who get a pizza and they just scrape the
toppings off right now
actually i'm like what happened to you
in your childhood yeah just get a pasta
see if sydney does that i die a bit
inside every time i see you just like
dunk your bread in some pasta sauce like
just bring like
just bring like a [ __ ] pasta like one
of those sauce pots with you like
why ruin some pizza like don't do that
this is not how i intended the new year
for to start by the way i did not think
i'd be honest i i intended to start this
like it's not trash taste without an
argument about food like i i don't know
who had the most clown opinion this
episode
no 90 percent of bread taste the same
all rice tastes the same bro come on
italian pizza american american pizza
everyone was a clown today ladies and
gentlemen
was a clown i'm glad we called this
trash taste it shields us from a lot of
criticism oh yeah let's just say that
yes because we say something
you can say all you want guys but we're
trash days
what did you expect i i like how we made
the name in preparation of us having
like shitty anime takes and like none of
us intended to ever talk about food
online right everyone is so scared to
give their like genuine opinions on
stuff yeah
like i'm talking like not just like
politics and all that yeah [ __ ] whatever
i don't give a [ __ ] about like
unimportant tell me your weird food
taste that you have that is really
honestly it's quite bizarre but you die
by it like like everyone has these
things yeah everyone everyone has a
weird taste because they were they were
you know brought up in a certain way or
they're not so familiar with a certain
type of cuisine or you know sometimes
taste buds don't always make sense you
can't have there's no there's no such
such thing as objective taste buds one
of my favorite dishes as a child that's
the most british thing i'm about to say
okay my mum would just make mashed
potatoes and spam
just mashed potato in the spam and then
just mash it all up and just give it to
me that's it like the whole place should
that be fair it does
sound like oh it could be good but
that's really [ __ ] i don't think i
could eat that like repeatedly i can
well yeah of course you can it sounds
like something where if you didn't eat
it as a kid but you wouldn't like maybe
she couldn't eat that just
the only reason i like is because i had
it since i was a baby
can you convince kids to like any food
yeah
i believe you can how do they convince
you to like natto but they can't
convince kids to like broccoli and stuff
and because the people who don't like
broccoli are babies they are they are
actually absolutely yeah they're
actually babies
how can babies like natto i don't know i
i like it maybe honey you know what it
is
big brain what kids love slime
kids [ __ ] love slime think about it
think about it yeah every single youtube
channel for kids is slime i mean
it's a conspiracy i'm getting the
[ __ ] red bull bro that's why kids in
japan that's why they love nacho because
it's slime i mean baby food no it's it's
it's not so is baby food with beans in
it it's slime look but like yes he's
always the slime right in front of us
this whole time right under our nose
like maybe
you know
broccoli or were we talking about
broccoli yeah yeah maybe broccoli just
doesn't taste good as like the main part
of the world the case with broccoli
isn't it the fact that like because kids
taste buds are more receptive to like
bitter flavors
as an adult and then and then as you get
you like broccoli yeah i love broccoli
do you like do you like i like broccoli
i love i love broccoli you give me like
a plate of broccoli and i put some mayo
on that [ __ ] and i can just eat it white
white
wait you didn't have broccoli
to be like controversial i thought this
was like normal
you just said that like it was like bro
i just like i just like grabbed the poop
out of the toilet just grab it i
actually eat it
it's good
try it
get some get them down to try this get
some like steamed broccoli right let's
get some cupid mayonnaise and then dip
it wait wait it's very common in japan
okay okay here's why i i recoiled for a
moment i had an image of you with a bowl
of broccoli and just pouring a bunch of
mayo but i've ordered from that chicken
and broccoli place it's all over japan
yeah it literally gives you it's awful
it's so bad it's like non-seasoned
boiled chicken right boiled broccoli
yeah and it's all prepared so they just
heat it up and send it to you yeah and
they charge you like 30 bucks yeah but
one of the dips they give you is low
calorie mayonnaise yeah i got to tell
you it goes hard doesn't it yeah
actually it's actually good like i just
realized i love yeah it's yeah you know
what actually friendship again yeah
thank you thank you that's good
exactly attained once again i think
god's the weird one yeah he definitely
yeah have you had it huh we should have
it well no he doesn't like condiments i
will say
okay
okay
no i i [ __ ] hate mayo normally but
living in japan keeping me alright well
i [ __ ] keeping mayo [ __ ] is
amazing yeah and like it's me it's
because i've just had shitty mayo my
entire life what do you put it on what
do you what do you mail with so whenever
it's in a sandwich right yeah yeah okay
next time you ever have steamed i feel
like i'm asking mark zuckerberg what is
being happy like uh in a sandwich
initiate happy process
no okay next time you have chicken and
broccoli just get some cupid mayo and
just like don't even have to drench that
[ __ ] just like a little bit is enough
because the mayo is already powerful
right you have a flavor just a little
bit wait wait wait when we get uh fried
chicken do you not like it with mayo
no because i like the taste of fried
chicken
i mean i was really good at like uh kind
of combating the oiliness of it and then
yeah
yeah somehow that's why a lot of like
another oily heavy liquid yeah
kind of mitigates yeah that's why like
with karaoke for example you always dip
it in mayo all right
i don't because just because i like the
taste of fried chicken oh with the mayo
it's [ __ ] it's kind of nice it's
amazing i don't know there are some
things where i i said i just like if
it's seasoned correctly then i i enjoy
that right because then then i enjoy the
taste of the seasoning rather than the
taste of the condiments you can't expect
but it's like it's like it's like you
have i'll have some of the chicken on
its own yeah i also have some of it with
the mess yeah just
try it out all right i did it
in the palette like i've said if
something tastes [ __ ] good i can eat
that thing infinitely that's like what
children do yeah
yeah sorry my taste buds actually work
on her so no no no no i would argue they
don't work because you're able to eat
the same thing over and over again
if it's good not if it's bad if if
something tastes good
you can't eat it over and over again eat
every day i can't i can't just go back
to it like you know so how like why do
you think it's so easy for me to eat
like i can easily eat the same meal
every day right now i'm like eating a
salad every day and it's fine it's
[ __ ] easy because salad tastes great
and like salad is like inoffensive it's
like it's like it's like saying oh i can
have water every day
i do have water every day
i'm not gonna lie i'm not really on
board with that argument i'm gonna
distance myself from that argument
that's this [ __ ] salad you know you
can't expect like the most like
grandiose like combination of flavors
unless you like drench that [ __ ] in
dressing well i mean i mean
other than that it's just like standard
vegetables i can eat the thing is i can
eat like some foods
okay
i i found this salad place and i really
liked it and i ordered it like maybe 10
days in a row i want to say the salad
and then now for some reason when i try
and eat it i know it's really good but i
just don't like it anymore why is that
because you got you got bored of it yeah
but isn't that sad well that's why you
don't eat the same thing every [ __ ]
day you're so damn good if it's
something that i [ __ ] love i
purposely try not to eat it often but
the reason i think the reason why i went
because there's nothing because there's
nothing because there's nothing that
terrifies me more than one day
sitting in front of my favorite meal
having a bite and going [ __ ] it doesn't
taste as good i just i i just i the
reason why right here's why his wife
okay if it was a pizza i wouldn't do it
every day you know why pizza is bad for
you oh yeah salad's good for you so i
was like don't mind if i do round eight
okay and then yeah i got bored of it and
i regret it because now i have a harder
time fighting healthier food that i like
eating so i really [ __ ] myself over
yeah that's like that's that's the real
problem when you can't have a salad
anymore
well that one type of salad that one
type of thing because because like my
biggest issue is that you know i have to
force myself to have a balanced diet
because i can i can easily eat something
the same thing every day if i really
really enjoy it yeah it's like
i could [ __ ] face
it no i'm not okay i could do this every
day yeah
i could [ __ ] eat lasagna every day
i'm not going to say it's healthy or
balanced but i can do it and i'm going
to eat it of course it's healthy of
course if mom made it of course it's
healthy
papa john's eat a pizza every day
he's still alive somehow
he's just the world's most greasiest
human being that's all [ __ ] hell oh
what a [ __ ] awful episode
[Music]
this has actually been probably the
worst episode of trash days
in terms of takes i hope you guys are
ready for 2022 because it might honestly
just get worse from here bro i feel like
i've got some concrete in my stomach i
don't know what it was from that i've
eaten today but it's probably the
[ __ ] pizza right no no no it couldn't
have been that that was the best thing
i've eaten that was the heaviest slice
of pizza i've had in a while it was
amazing it was good for another one yeah
can't believe but that's a problem in
japan right it tastes good but you gotta
pay 22 dollars for that time yeah yeah
that's true
so offensive little caesar's out here i
mean it might honestly be a blessing
because if it costs the same as an
american pizza yo i'd be like 500. it's
the biggest deterrent in terms you know
you know what we should do actually we
should make trash taste pizza we should
make uh we should make a food three by
three one of these days and pick and
pick the nine dishes that we we we're
gonna we're gonna defend the nine dishes
that's going to be like the most toxic
episode four hour trash taste episode
that's going to be like the most toxic
episode of trash taste that's ever been
made people skip through that episode
we picked the nine dishes that we didn't
live with you know what what format is
really [ __ ] horrible and what but
just leads to people tearing their
throats out they're like where you put
stuff in like a tournament bracket that
shouldn't be in a tournament bracket oh
they put like video games in a
tournament bracket like the best one get
goes through and it was like what was
voted the best game it was like uh
gta
right oh god of all whatever is the best
game that's the best game yeah like
ign's bracket or something we should do
that oh i mean it's [ __ ] we should do
a food bracket how long would that sound
food tournament yeah no no no no no no
no no no no no no no no no no okay we
can't we we come down okay and we have
to agree what is the best food okay okay
okay no i i i got it i got it luckily
we're we're we're three so we're okay oh
yeah that's right i've got it we're
gonna make the food three by three we're
gonna present present our favorite foods
and then we are going to have the
bracket for the viewers to vote for and
then we're gonna present the winner or
we're gonna present the tournament
results on a live stream or something
we're going to tear each other's throats
we just put more food there then because
it would be like yeah that's true
okay
but look forward to that i guess in the
meantime here are the patrons look at
them all they lost
if they're still
here
i wouldn't be surprised if you're almost
like yo this ain't worth fighting for
the italians who clocked out an hour and
a half ago
i just want to imagine what it's like
being an audience member in this episode
to be like yeah he's he's saying
something that makes sense oh no i love
it well we have like people who are like
food scientists watching oh yeah yeah
yeah you're like actually and i'm like
listen
i don't give a [ __ ]
taste buds go bro you know what i mean
like i i i mean they're only 40 for you
i mean they're all having an aneurysm in
front of the screens right i do
apologize for any food experts out there
yeah um i might not be uh right but i'm
anecdotally correct so that's all that
matters and that's why we're in a
political situation that no one agrees
you know you know at least you know i
may have some clown takes but at least
i'm friends with some fellow clowns
especially exactly this is this is the
circus
this is not trash taste this is the
circus now this is the circus this is
the circus but hey if you'd like to join
the circus then uh make sure to go to
our patreon patreon.com society that's a
lot about the circus doesn't it also
it's also follow us on twitter send us a
message on the subreddit and if you had
fs listen to us on spotify i think this
is the first time we've literally had
every one of our cast members to speak
out against something we've won
individually individually said before we
wrap this up where the [ __ ] is
grindelwald where's grindelwald what oh
why isn't he on the shelves bro i don't
know the best figure from the whole
purchasing uh he's he's in the corner
bring him out bring him out give him
here give him right here come on let's
put him on the table there we go leave
him right there
all right there we go come on i thought
you were talking about the majora's mask
there i was i was like wait uh does uh
does it have another name is his name
brindlewald joey
tell him tell them to [ __ ] off all right
[ __ ] off
[Music]
you